Oh Shit.
I think fall off those pieces of shit season when you don't Bro.
Yeah,
they get too fancy or whatever.
That's what we got.
Another one.
Oh Wow.
What would I already go?
Sorry.
Cheers sir.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
Don't know.
We were talking about the different kinds of comedians that there really are
like mean comedians there.
They're comedians.
They have a special skillset.
It's a different thing.
In fact,
one of my closest friends,
bearded humor,
he's like,
um,
I would say if he was a standup comic he would probably be be in my top five in
terms of creativity,
in terms of talking about things in a moment and just all are funny.
You know,
the skill set for stand up now.
It used to be I started 25 years ago.
It used to be Tony,
where you proved yourself as a person with any type of comedic integrity while I
was on stage standing flat footed in front of an audience that you probably
don't want you to be funny or no have have no idea.
You can be funny.
But these main,
these many people,
Photoshop,
especially because our attention is so quick.
And so John to social media,
media people,
I don't even know if people are as excited about stand up as they used to be.
A nail is excited about what's going to be the newest thing.
What's gonna be,
what's gonna be the hardest photo?
The photo shop was gonna be the hardest image.
Well,
that's the easiest to get,
right?
It's easier to get it on your phone.
You get those images,
the photoshops and the memes that are funny that hit you immediately.
But I think right now,
I mean,
especially when you go to the store,
don't you think there's like more people interested in standup now than ever?
Yeah,
but it's,
so we,
we in in a tricky place now.
People are interested in it,
but people are so,
they're more critical of stand up now more than ever.
It used to be a time when you could just say what you want it.
And people say that that person was outspoken.
Outrageous.
But they were themselves.
But now you tell one joke,
uh,
one blogger,
one troller dissects your jokes and print your jokes.
Don't do the setup,
don't do a call back,
don't do the tag.
And next thing you know,
you offended somebody.
Yeah.
But I think with a lot of events that happen today that are happening now,
comedy's going to start taking it a shift back to people on his voices.
I think so too.
I think there's a direct backlash to like political correct thinking and the,
the type of policing that you're seeing.
You see,
you'd been pleased and I understand polices and stuff in the Catholic church,
police stuff in a regular church,
but you go to a comedy club to police you,
we're in the wrong place.
And nine times out of 10 people that go to a comedy show there,
walk out in protest,
their mindset was to protest before they even went there.
They're just waiting for the trigger word just to be like,
well,
I never,
they leave.
Well,
it's a way
to get a lot of attention,
you know,
being outraged.
It's something,
especially if you kind of have a point,
like if you could articulate that point,
right.
It's a great way to get attention.
The trollers and the people that,
yeah,
I mean there's a,
there's a giant market for that.
Like if you think of like a,
if you're a comic and you're a famous comic and you're outspoken,
you know,
and someone could take your bit and take it apart like they've done with
Chappelle when many times,
right?
Oh,
Chappelle owns it so much.
He owns it.
I was just with him and you I've never seen to got it flips our sets over like
he just riding another five minute bit.
It's weird.
Right.
But the thing with the thing is now I've watched some of his new stuff and
things he doing now.
He's going to lead the charge for comedians having a voice.
I did a show with him at the store recently and at the end of it he said,
comedians now more than ever,
you need to grab your balls because it's our job to talk about the things that
are bad in his world and we are the best people forward.
What's the last line of free speech?
It's the last real line of free speech because you don't have a real boss,
right?
Like when you go onstage,
it's no one's,
no one gives you a single word of direction,
right.
You know,
that's,
that's a very unusual place to be in,
in terms of entertainment and something that reaches,
especially with someone like Dave millions and millions and millions of people.
Every time he does a Netflix special,
every time somebody he does anything that's filmed,
it's going to hit millions of people.
They have no one telling you what to do.
No one,
no one giving you when they tried to tell you what to do,
you you've resisted in did you do what you want to do?
He's a real comic.
He's a real that I've been following you for a,
I've been a comedy store for years.
I'm always in the cut and I've seen you do some material like how the fuck does
he get away with this
because he fucking owns it.
And that's totally believe what I'm saying.
And a lot of ways,
like in other things it's obvious that I don't really believe it,
but I'm saying it because I think it's funny and opinion.
Tommy as for us,
as much as people are like,
oh I need that.
I think for Comedians is therapeutic for us too.
Yeah,
there's 100% can you imagine a situation?
You have an argument with your wife or somebody and you can't go on stage at
night just to talk about how pissed off she made you.
That's how outlet.
Yeah.
So as much as people get stuff out of us,
when you come to a show,
we get now our psychiatric exam right on spot.
You're also like,
you could complain about some Shit,
you can complain about someone saying something or something happened or you
could turn it into a bit and you can get hundreds of people just dying laughing.
All,
I have had some,
I had some conflicts online.
One of them with a bunch of vegans.
They so you entertain so much.
You're trying to be,
you're like,
I don't got time for that.
I'm not going to entertain me every once while you just want to punch a troller
phages would read the comments.
That was the problem is occasionally you read the comments are like Holy Shit,
like people just want you dead because anyway,
I had to told the thing in my act about a chasing down the Hashtag Vegan
cat,
somebody wrote to mean shit to me and have this Hashtag Vegan cattles like what
the fuck is that?
I went there and there's a whole community of people feed their cats vegetables
and,
but,
but in,
in,
in doing this and like tracking this down and,
and like it,
it makes you realize like,
okay,
I got to write a bit about this cause I could just get mad.
Easily writes,
it writes itself.
I could just get mad and be upset that someone's being mean to me or I can turn
this shit into fuel or you could just go fuck it.
Just destroy the whole Vegan community.
There's nothing,
it's not the feet.
It's nothing wrong with vegans.
Is has the same shit is every other group.
I don't really know too many vegans aren't assholes,
Bro.
I know some vegans.
It aren't assholes.
I don't know.
Rich Roll.
He's a great guy.
John Joseph.
Neal Brennan.
He's a Vegan.
He's an asshole.
He's a little bit of it,
man.
Bill Brennan is a mother fucking prick.
What are you talking about man?
Telling people to turn into s when the asshole is in body in him,
especially people wear glasses because they were,
they have like million different frames.
Ooh,
that's when you add the next level of being an asshole when you switched your
glasses up.
But Neil Brennan is a Vegan and he's one of those,
I don't think vegans should it be allowed to go to a barbecue and complained.
They could play.
They all come to a fucking barbecue.
They got their panties.
They're upset.
If you've been cooking meat on a grill that was designed to cook dead animals,
they'll sort of tend to get up and they'd get upset.
So all vegans are assholes.
I'm sorry it's not all of them,
but I see what you're saying.
All the ones that I
did it because it cause when I make them,
but they made the transition.
It can't just become vegans.
They got,
they just got to let you know I'm Vegan now.
It can wait.
You say dinner,
is it Vegan options?
It Vegan,
Vegan.
They just can't do it.
They got to make an announcement.
I think I let everybody know that I'm a Vegan and now and I'm an asshole.
They think they're saving the world and the worst is a Vegan that always gets
cold.
Yo,
whenever I see Neal Brennan Coffee,
whenever I see a car say,
so how's that big a live call?
You fucking flew habit ass motherfucker.
How he say that to Ian Edwards?
I'm like,
dude,
you are tired.
You're exhausted.
I take pictures of each and every time we fly together and he falls asleep.
I take pictures of me and just sit there.
I'm like,
look,
you need some motherfucking protein that they have be 12 and your diet.
Get a stake in your motherfucking daddy.
He said he would eat meat,
but he would only eat elk that I killed.
He said he would eat some uh,
some elk meets.
I'm going to cook him some elk meat.
We're going to,
we should film it.
It probably like bounce around like super person.
Like he's been eating nothing but lentils for the last 20 years.
Elk.
How of,
where does one go to even shoot an elk?
Utah.
Colorado has a lot of them there.
Some of them.
Twitter.
How do you,
how do you transport?
Is there a loss?
Can you transport your killer?
You have to break it down wherever where you kill it.
You are,
you have to have,
uh,
first of all,
you have a tag
and then when you,
when you have a tag,
you're allowed to get a certain kind of animal.
So say if it's like,
uh,
you have,
a buck deer tag,
that means you can kill a male deer.
And then once you kill it,
then you break it down and you either bring it to a butcher shop and they turn
it into cuts for you.
Or You could do it yourself and wrap it up,
but you have to have a tag.
You have to register that you killed that animal and you have to keep that,
that,
that with you,
that paperwork with you.
So if you transport the,
the meat across state lines and some game warden pulled you over and said,
you have a deer in your car.
I knew he asked her,
do sir?
And he's got to see that you have the paperwork for it.
I don't want to sound racist and all,
but I don't know a black person that could tell that story you just told about
killing butchering up to transport in a dead end.
Yeah,
that's what you have to do.
That's how you do it.
You got to put them on ice.
I mean you have to,
you have an obligation to try to save the meat.
You know when you have an animal and it's down,
you want to get it into like a packaged form as quick as possible.
You want to break it down.
Sometimes it's like,
dude,
sometimes people hang things.
They hang things in their garage
cold too.
So you wouldn't,
you mentioned were hanging on I think about is Jesse's son.
Oh my God.
Talk about said No.
A whole bunch of people back in one interview.
Crazy story itches.
It such a mess.
It's a mess and I think was really awful about it because his story,
it was,
it was like good and bad of it to good of it was when people thought that he was
violated and he was a victim of a hate crime.
It wasn't just gay people.
There was a Russian to support him.
It was like thug dudes,
you know what I'm saying?
It was like some real motherfuckers.
Dell was like,
I mean,
I saw exhibit,
make a comment.
It was a community of people away from the LBG community that thought it was
really fucked up.
Yeah.
And that's,
that was the beauty of the incident because it kind of put people together.
But the fun thing about it was just a lot and it's so fucking unfortunate.
It's so unfortunate that somebody would play on people's emotions for or to
benefit themselves.
It's,
it's awful.
Well,
there's a certain narcissism that exists in show business that I think you and I
both know very well.
You know,
we've all seen it and thankfully the people that seem to be the best for
whatever reason,
they have the,
some of the best handles on it.
Like Dave doesn't show any of that.
Right.
But there's some people that do and that narcissism is weird,
that that wanting it to be all about them and then they'll do sneaky shit,
like fake and attack.
That's,
that's a symptom of that same kind of thinking.
It just,
it just got desperate and went in some crazy way.
It was officer a reason,
because you have like when I first
went down,
you had people that normally people that you look at,
okay,
that's my friend or whoever,
you started having side eyes and that's just,
it's just,
it's so messed up.
And I think also as messed up as much as people wrote for him when he thought
that it was an injustice,
everything,
nobody's really talking about it.
Nobody's addressing it.
Like,
you know,
this is our movement.
These are things that we were trying to progress toward.
But this was an isolated incident and just say how awful it was.
No.
You know,
the beautiful thing is that people are way more tolerant than they ever have
been before.
They're also beautiful things attack didn't happen.
Right?
So I don't have to think of one more atrocious thing that people have done to
another person for no reason.
Right.
So that's good.
And it's also good that you get to see where that kind of stuff heads where
you're always looking to be a victim to the point where you realize there's like
some sort of currency and being a victim.
So people fake being a victim so they can get all this fucking attention.
It's good for us.
It's good for us to see cause you see that now next time a story comes around
that just a little fishy I'm guessing.
Exactly.
It's like the boy who cried wolf and that's what's unfortunate about it because
anytime someone says that they were a victim of such a heinous crime like that,
you want to believe him,
you want to believe them.
The mean they said,
then it makes you start second guessing thing.
And that's another thing.
It was awful about the whole thing and all the smoke he's getting right now and
he deserved,
because I've been tearing his ass up on Instagram on everything he does.
He deserves every bit he knows he deserves,
everybody knows he deserves it.
I read it.
I read a story once about this dude who said that he punished his daughter by
making her sit in the backyard by a tree.
And then he went out there an hour later and she was gone.
And the suspect that coyotes got her.
And I remember thinking that story going,
man,
that just does not sound real.
That does not sound real.
It just seems weird.
It's kind of left a baby in the backyard and coyotes got it.
Like one was like a new,
like a black not walking or anything like that.
Well,
he left the baby,
like to punish the baby like a two year old.
Left it in the,
well,
it turns out he really didn't do that.
The kid died and he'd stuffed it in some drainage ditch somewhere.
So this,
uh,
I don't remember how the kid died.
What was the reason for it?
But it was one of those stories.
We hear this toy,
you like Jesus.
It doesn't sound real.
Sometimes stories don't sound real.
The next thing we're going to be second guessing everything.
I hope not.
But when it first went down,
I thought it was a,
I've thought it was a situation where Lee Daniels and Jesse sat down in a
writer's room and Lee Daniels,
Lee,
anybody got any ideas for any new episodes?
It just like,
I got one.
Nobody's going to believe it.
Look,
I'm going to be hungry as shit,
right?
I'm going to go to subway to get a 12 inch footlong.
Ellie Daniel was like,
I believe that
avenue,
that part I did with her,
the whole story elite.
Dan,
you said to them,
nobody's going to believe it.
Jesse got upset.
It told the totally Dez,
we'll see.
I'm going to shoot it myself,
and he walked to self into the that whole scenario and it's just
awful.
That's entirely possible.
That's what it sounds like.
It sound like,
you know,
you're going to say now anybody that was a fan of empire,
which I know a lot of people that's listening work being very sarcastic when I
say that they're gonna be like second guessed the storyline of so many of those
shows,
the storylines of everybody to whoever said today we're done wrong or anything
you'd,
the awful thing about this is now people are going to be ready and quick to just
second guess anything that you say.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a fact.
Until we can read each other's minds till we could find out for sure that's
going to change the whole game.
The reason why his mind.
Yeah,
that's definitely gonna eliminate a lot of street fights.
Most of them I made you talk about your,
your imminent danger sensors are going to be 100% if you read somebody's mind.
Yeah.
I don't know if I want to do that.
I do.
I like him a secrets.
No Marlin.
I like having secrets too,
but I like going all in.
I think all in,
I think,
I think it's just inevitable.
We were talking about it in the last podcast about there's something they're
going to be able to shoot into your neck and what did he say the way he
described it,
like an injection that will take over sort of the way it interacts with your
brain cells thread thread itself in your brain house.
So literally like having,
I think we're going to have built in Wifi Internet systems where we're connected
to each other's heads.
So this is what people request was like a study they going to try out on people
or you can just go to your doctor and say,
shoot me with the brain shit.
I think eventually it's going to be shooting with the brain shit first you got
to get it on a clinical trial,
going to be able to be like a heroin addict and so do you get for that?
Like who is close to no brain cells and shit and that's when we try it on it.
But what was that movie?
There was a movie where a dude got shot and they put some chip in his back
upgrade.
That's great.
Yeah,
and it did that to him.
It turned up and he like at an access to all the information.
He knew martial arts,
he knew how to move and everything was happening like that.
He was a basically like a super computer inside of a person that to do
everything,
just official intelligence is right down the line.
If they're talking about this shit,
shooting it in your brain,
we're going to share a network.
We're all going to be on a network.
It's going to be a lot of white people joining that effort because black people
don't fuck with needles,
Bro.
We don't do none of that unless less is heroin.
We don't take out Bruh.
I'm telling you.
Oh,
say that.
But how many,
how many athletes are on steroids?
Yeah,
but that's a different,
that's a different animal.
I'm talking about the average black dude that's strictly in Brownsville or watch
or something like that.
Yo,
I got this new brain shit.
We objected through a needle.
They go fuck you up.
They don't wanna hear that shit.
That's hilarious.
And that's probably true.
I mean how many people are going to try that?
Like who's going to be the earliest adopter or getting an a shot in your neck.
The lets you read everybody's mind and then what are you going to do?
What?
It is an interesting thing.
It's going to fuck our job up man.
Because like half of what we do is say shocking shit that people know is kind of
true.
But you can't believe you're saying that people are always like,
oh not the old winter's Joe coming up.
You've got that.
If you could do that,
that'd be the ultimate fucking joke.
Gator right there.
Oh yeah.
Two guys walk in a bar.
You don't get anything happening.
That's nothing.
I think I had to pass on it.
Keep it bro.
Yeah,
it's going to be weird.
When would you get it?
Like you wouldn't would,
you wouldn't be the first comedian to have it.
Oh,
you almost want to be a fool who doesn't have it.
If you want to be a comedian,
I want to watch other motherfuckers do it first.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'll in the back.
But the problem is they're going to fucking take over like finances,
like instantly they're gonna.
As soon as they upload their brand and they're like,
I just couldn't get all this money.
I'm going to figure out a way to get all this fucking money and then by the time
you shoot it into your head,
they've already got the system locked down.
But see that's,
you have different level of people that you hang out with because your level be
like,
well how would we get the money but my level be like,
Yo,
we got this brace your,
how are we going to get some ass off of his dog?
You can get it.
You'll be more read a broad mind.
You get all the asked you all of it.
Yeah.
You would know,
but then it wouldn't be fun like half the fun is not known.
If somebody likes you,
right?
You don't know what's going to happen here.
It's just going to work out.
What was that movie with Mel Gibson or he could,
he could read women's minds what,
what women want and they remade it.
Right now it's coming out.
I've seen the billboard.
That's hilarious.
Henson and Tracy Morgan.
Tracy money.
I had a conversation with Mel Gibson the other day on the phone.
It was one of the weirdest things in my life.
I'm just happy to know.
I have friends that could say that.
So you have a lot of sentences.
My friends get you.
You know how you kill an elk.
All right,
here's drivetrain a bucket.
So it's,
so you got triggered what time it then it's like,
oh it a yes,
so I'm on the phone with Mel Gibson.
The other day I was on the phone with ray ray the other day.
Well,
I'd rather be on the front with Ray Ray.
It's not bad to talk to Mel Gibson.
It's just,
it's like,
okay,
he's a regular,
he's a dude.
He's a guy.
He's Mel Gibson,
Mel Gibson.
But he like fucking for real like you talking to me.
Like for real.
It's a real conversation with Mel Gibson.
How would be,
that would be very interesting and I've never run into him.
He's a super nice guy.
He did a podcast to talk about the stem cell doctor that helped his dad.
Oh yeah.
He came on for Doctor Neil Riordan.
He's this guy in Dallas that treats people down in Panama,
has got this radical stem cells therapy that you can't get in America.
And it fixed.
Mel Gibson's dad was 92 and he was in a wheelchair and now he's a hundred and
he's walking around.
He's an issue with stem cells situation and America's,
I don't hear it too much the last time.
I'm not probably as knowledge as you are,
but wasn't,
I'm Christopher Reeves trying to um,
promote stem,
more stem cell research.
I'm sure he was.
Yeah.
He had that spinal cord injury from a horse for horse accident.
He was doing those horse jumps.
Yeah,
South Park thing.
Remember,
I don't remember
eating dead babies to like get the stem cells.
12 years is we'll take a bad turn
about rape on South Park.
They don't give a fuck.
They're the best.
They're also pushing the boundaries
like change.
They're the ones out there that are promoting like ridiculous,
preposterous comedy that's completely offensive but brilliant.
That's one of the things that when we were doing Chappelle show,
the,
one of the things I appreciate more than anything about this show was how it put
people of all races,
all backgrounds together to do the thing that we all should have in common.
In as to laugh and also to not push the button but touch on retro stuff without
having angry undertone.
And this was so fucked up about American.
Now whenever you talk about race,
it feels like one side,
somebody has to tint be tense.
You know what I'm saying is never like a comfortable saves.
Never like,
and I know things are intense,
but we,
we have to be able to laugh first.
Once you get people to laugh,
you can talk about whatever you want and then even if a person is not in
agreement or have the same thoughts at the end of the day,
you should be able to respect that person.
And I think those same people should be able to share a laugh.
Yeah.
And there was a a fun,
silly non aggressive quality to the way you guys put together sketches that got
the point across and everybody laughed.
Everybody laughed at my joke to this.
To this day when I traveled,
I do my audiences.
It's interesting because of course you would think I'm going to draw a certain
audience because I'm black,
which I,
you know,
which I am and I do,
but it's weird.
I could go to places in a straight up like Dave,
column d,
The muddy boot motherfuckers,
you know what I'm saying?
Like the money book motherfuckers,
the money boost to jail,
they got John Deere.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
They know all that elk shit you talking about,
you know,
do John Deere is no,
all this shit.
They probably call her right now and say,
no,
Joe,
I think you got done wrong.
You got to cut the heart from,
you know,
you've got to go left or right.
You know what I'm saying?
And I've noticed I have those people and then I have heard people,
but it's just interesting when you can look out and this is what that showed it.
When you can look at an audience and you say you have all of America there,
it was the best sketch comedy show in the history of television,
I think.
I think in living color is very,
very,
very overlooked.
People forget how God Damn Day was hilarious and groundbreaking.
It was bright in both of them.
Like it's wherever I go,
people always,
they always bring it up is a big point in my career.
But I was like every,
I don't know ever happens every 10 years or 15 years.
It comes a time where,
uh,
the audience wants something different.
Yeah.
That's sick shit.
Water down.
Same way when in living color.
Same Way with def comedy jam came out,
you know,
you,
you didn't see a lot of uh,
a black standups on TV,
but they had this underground circuit.
It was bubbling.
That was bubbling and it was,
it was the right time when they pulled out to the right time and live in color
comes around.
It's the right time.
Yeah.
Dave Chappelle show comes around.
It's the right time to Richard Show.
Even though that only lasted three or four episode,
it was the right time and it caught on it the right time.
Yeah.
Um,
in terms of like groundbreaking sketch comedy shows though,
like that,
that,
that KKK bit where he had the,
uh,
the line,
let me tell you something.
Do you understand in the history of sketch,
nobody has premiered a schedule and it came off so hardcore the first night.
It's hot as hell.
She's hard as it comes.
When they ended that Shit,
when,
when we asked why,
why after all these years would you still,
so he was like,
because she's a nigger lover.
I was like,
that was one of them.
That was one of the joints.
I'm like,
wake up everybody no more sleeping in bed.
No.
From that moment that this show was going to be on the next level of shops.
Well was he was free.
It was,
there was so many when we did,
funny thing,
a lot of things I used to do,
I was a warm up comedian for Chappelle show.
So whenever you saw Chappelle show episode in,
have you noticed that?
Whenever I came on screen
and I'm not being cocky,
people who go nuts,
they be like,
oh shit.
And the reason was because I was a guy that wanted the ordinance before Dave
came out.
Ah.
So I knew if I go gut the room out at the beginning,
people don't,
people don't even,
they didn't,
nobody knew I was there anything.
If I ripped that at the beginning and then when they see me on the screen,
it's going to be like,
it's going to be big.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that show,
man,
it was just like,
it was just loud.
A lot of things happen.
And show people like Rick James Sketch the day we played that on a wrap arounds.
Man,
I should hit so hard.
I was like,
this shit is fucking crazy crazy.
One thing people don't know is that comedy central did not like that sketch
comedy central.
Here's this funny kind of guessed.
It comes such didn't think Charlie Murphy.
Oh,
Swanee unit.
Okay.
And I watched,
we ran as shit sick just to let you know the direction people think I wasn't
shit six times and every time,
every time you heard Dave say,
I'm Rick James Bitch,
it was guts.
It was gut side.
Yo went to the five figure,
say to the face,
what does lance I yet to sketch was getting kids to spend it in school,
right?
He was born in school day teachers.
What are the five things they say?
But I'm Rick James Bitch.
All right.
Tom used to spend four week,
you add Dave Chappelle.
Go to the fucking time.
Out Room is one of the most iconic sketches of all time.
How wrong was comedy central?
I mean,
not just a little wrong.
A lot.
I'll,
I'll along the way wrong all the way wrong.
Like almost like suicidal.
It was like,
hmm.
But then it goes to show us like it goes to show,
you know how you have a vision with something.
You see it.
Yeah.
Everybody may not see it.
Well that's the problem with working with executives to right.
It's like their vision is different than your vision.
They,
you'd like to shape you in a certain way and you know,
and I know Dave ran into problems with
them wanting them to change language so they could get more sponsors.
Yeah.
I think,
I think that that wasn't an issue.
And to be quite honest,
I don't know exactly what happened.
Everything is speculation.
He never talked to him about,
never talked to him about it because the reason why I never talked to him about
it because I didn't need to talk to them about it.
You know what I'm saying?
Um,
that show was great for me.
It was a great Frey platform for me and then out.
It was more important,
my friendship and how he felt away from that was more important then.
So why did you leave?
Right?
Where'd you go?
First Time I saw him or like as long as you okay.
Cause this to be scary for anybody.
One of your closest friends,
somebody you work with all of a sudden just goes to another country.
You don't hear from him,
you know?
But when I first saw him after that,
like I was excited and I would just like,
you know,
with whatever it was,
we had a moment we may history and people go on,
people going to do other things and just keep it moving.
Well that show was really,
people always say Danielle,
if it wasn't for the Chapelle show,
this and that.
Japan's show gave me a platform for people to see what I've been doing for
years.
And you know,
you see talents in the club now you see a muffin is good shit,
good shit.
But when they get the right platform for the world series,
you know what I'm saying?
And that's kind of separate.
Um,
you see one person go from one level to the next level who has the right
platform to showcase their talent.
And that show did that for me.
And with that said,
I gave that show everything every time I had a second on camera every time,
like if you look at two and a half years on this show,
if you had an editor breakdown how many times I spoke,
it would probably be a total of four minutes.
I'll get a word here,
I get a phrase here,
but I told myself whenever they turn out motherfucking camera I'm going for it.
Like even if I'm not talking I'm going to make my body so expressive that your
eyeball draws too with,
I remember Neal told me one time,
he said because I always,
I always get a mic cause I'll come up with a line or something to throw in.
And we were doing a Rick James Sketch and I didn't have a mic.
I was like Yo uh sound.
And Neil said you're not going to get a mic bro.
I said I might,
I might.
I was like I might say something like you're not going to say anything.
I was like fuck.
So I told myself,
well he smacks this motherfucker cause if you look at that scene where he smacks
me,
I said,
what the f?
I was like,
um,
like uh,
uh,
Washington square park mime.
I pushed that.
I said what thought fuck I made my face.
He didn't give me a mic,
but I said what the fuck with my face.
And I always as people always as a matter of showing up as the young actors and
stuff like that,
you talk to me,
what do you need to do?
I was like with anything,
the best thing to do is figure out a way to get on a set.
You get on a set,
you,
you do blackmail,
you learn,
you get opportunities,
you got to be around it.
You got to get a skill set.
But when it's time to show up,
you gotta show up.
You have to show up [inaudible] talk a lot of shit.
I want to do this out there.
And then when I say action of,
I'm saying when you show up and every time I fucking say actually in situation
you got to show up.
Well,
you have a great ability to express yourself on stage and on TV.
Some people feel uncomfortable,
they just like to be cool while they're telling the jokes or like some people
have that style.
Like your style is big,
you know,
I appreciate it.
You know,
you ever see Jim Brewer?
Yeah,
I saw Jim brewer like the first time I saw him we were really young.
Jim Brewer.
Yeah,
we were real young and my manager Jason Steinburge says,
what's up?
Tell him I said what's up?
No doubt.
When I first saw brewer,
he's so physical and I remember saying,
I remember you get tired of watching him.
I remember,
I remember Jim Bro.
Like Boston comedy club days.
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean that's why we use mentioned his name.
I was like,
yeah,
which is Jim Borough.
Are we speaking of?
I mean you didn't today.
Our Dad,
Jim Breuer today.
I mean he's still real energetic,
but I'm telling you when I tell you I used to,
I saw him in his super prime,
he was a murderer and he was,
he destroyed,
destroyed,
like shut the light,
like who's going to do anything after that?
You know who dude,
I ain't shit fall on him once.
One of the worst bombings in my entire career I was headlining and Jim was and
we were working together.
We did.
Millan is a prime spot to fuck somebody up.
That's a price.
By 2025 we had a good mc two so the MC was like got the crowd,
really pop it and then the middle came on and jam chest rip the place up.
He may have to apart and I was scared and I had a blown out ACL at the time and
I was wearing cavalry cheese.
I was wearing like a sexy pants.
Oh Shit.
I'm like too much information.
Pause side with these stupid pants and people were in the eighties man,
like they were tied at the top and they flared out a little.
I'm not going to see almost like a little bit.
They're pathetic.
That thought.
Can't believe ever owned them but they were in style.
That's what I have that like that Bro.
Seriously.
You're not sure.
No Elk.
A number of no you're not.
I think mine were probably jeans.
The jeans ones like that.
Like see the far left and the blue right there.
Bam.
Yeah,
mine.
That's awesome.
Terrible.
That's all.
Can I wear those?
And they have a straight face and then I had like some nice dress up shirt on
and I just ate plates of Shit.
But it made me rethink my whole act cause it was,
it was so such a humiliating bombing and I,
cause I knew that they,
the audience was right.
I wasn't being funny.
I was nervous and scared about it.
Those are the moments that make you 100% like now I see a comedy.
Like I go to some clubs,
motherfuckers trying to do the lineup kind of soft like well we can't that
person
in front of that person because they won't be able to follow blah blah blah.
But it should be a point like when I,
when I started like the baddest motherfuckers on the game,
they went on stage and if he was a new jack coming up,
how are you going to have a defining moment in comedy?
You've got a go behind somebody.
Anybody can do.
If you've got a hot room,
everybody's doing good but put that shit behind where you got them off fucking
like a bill.
Burke comes in the room and just goes and fucks it up.
What do you stand up?
We did,
I did a tour with him bill.
And it's so interesting cause I know they have one of those podcasts where to
theme is,
have you ever had to come behind a distillery?
I forget to podcast it desert but crystal if you ever had to come behind a story
of coming behind someone that just the most going on after them.
And then Krista live I saw Kristala do once he said me and that but when we were
doing Chappelle should have to Chappelle show after second year Chappelle show.
We weren't really making a lot of money on special cause the show still hadn't
been proven.
You know something you got to,
if you've got a contract,
you've got contract.
That's it just so happened to cause the show blew up before the contract was
over.
But that don't mean nobody's going to renegotiate.
So we had this popular,
but we weren't making money.
And um,
I came with the idea that doing a tour called the I'm rich bitch tour and at the
time,
at the time Charlie was China,
like anywhere he goes,
at the time bill burr was um,
uh,
a headliner probably at the time and be rooms,
you know what I'm saying?
And this is no disrespect to him,
but he was on the come up.
Right.
But when you saw bill,
you knew this muffled was going to be next.
You knew he was going,
he was going to pop it.
But we still wasn't getting no cash.
Charlie had never told jokes and I was like,
how the fuck you around all these communities?
You never been on stage.
So I used to bully him.
You know,
he tough ass motherfucker,
rest in peace.
But I was like,
yeah,
you so tough motherfucker,
but not with a microphone in your hand.
And I bullied them so much that he finally went on stage and Charlie,
we,
the tour was Charlie would mc and all we needed him to do was 10 or 15 minutes
at the time.
Me and Charlie outside of the day were to pop up people on the show.
Bill bird had a couple of sketches per bill burgeon pop off of the show.
And I,
and I was like,
but if we're going to do this,
let's have a fire show.
You know what I mean?
Don't we could put somebody's weak in the middle.
I said,
let's give them a show that they won't ever forget.
And Charlie used to come out to 10 or 15 minutes and I tell people that,
I was like,
who's the toughest person to follow?
But Charlie,
we got through 10 15 minutes and Bill Burger would come out and do 20 to 25 and
then I came behind bill,
not one night for a year,
a whole year.
And Bill Burns a type of act.
You have no days off.
You have no or any of that,
any,
any little inkling of being off.
You're just gonna hear.
Yeah,
I liked the show,
but the white dude was funny as a motherfucker,
you know,
and he,
you could tell that time there,
Bill Byrd was going to be a star,
whether it would have been movies or television,
but as a stand up,
you know,
he was one pound for pound,
one of the dope dopest to do it.
And I tore,
went off a fucking year.
We had a blast.
Yeah.
Bill's brilliant.
Uh,
I got to work with Charlie for,
we did this maxim tour.
We did like 22 dates.
Me and him and John [inaudible],
we traveled all over the place when Charlie was starting to do it.
It was,
he kind of looks like two years in,
he was two years in at the time.
And you know what people judge,
people understand how tough it is to start as a comedian has a famous person as
a comedian that you're basically,
you're open miker does selling out all across the country.
And not only that,
but you're Eddie Murphy's brother.
So you got to fight past all of that shit,
creating your own identity.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I could not imagine like the heat he probably had.
Yeah.
But he,
Eddie Murphy,
Hey Eddie Murphy.
And that's one of the things that when Charlie passed that I really appreciated
about what the Chappelle show did for him.
Because when he passed away,
nobody said Eddie Murphy's brother died.
Right.
Everybody's like Charlie marries passed away.
So he had his true identity and that was Charlie Murphy.
Yeah.
And that was one of his bits.
You know,
the,
you know,
is it,
does it piss you off for people?
[inaudible] he was,
I'm just happy to not call me Eddie Murphy's brother anymore.
It's fun.
I remember that.
That was at that time.
That was one that was a joke and addressed it.
And it just kept on and he,
and,
and he found himself,
he got better,
he got better.
And then he carved his own lane.
He called us,
he carved his own lane.
Did.
I was with Maury Smith used to be the UFC heavyweight champion and a Ivan
salivary,
who's a guy who fought in the middleweight division in the UFC and a couple
other professional fighters at a table with Charlie Murphy and trial.
He was explaining how none of these motherfuckers know how to do a Chicago Ridge
hand karate shit.
Oh,
he was big on it,
but it,
it's like Charlie Murphy's holding court,
standing up.
All these UFC fighters is taking it back.
And Charlie Murphy was talking about Ridge hand and it's a talking about,
and he knew exactly what he's talking about.
Right.
He knew how to fight for sure.
I've had,
he had,
he,
he never knew martial arts.
He was,
um,
he was big into it years ago.
He used to be on at his body guy when Eddie was like right at the height of his
stuff.
But um,
Charlie was like martial arts,
but everything that he said,
it was the truth.
You know what I mean?
You didn't feel it like,
oh,
this dude is lying.
Everything.
He said it was true and one of the most genuine people you want to meet man.
Just a dope guy.
Yeah,
his karate lineage,
like he has some sort of a connection to some of my friends.
I'd have to ask them,
but he was like a legit martial artists.
I saw one video of him in a martial arts contest and it was,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I always tell him,
I was like,
Yo,
you knocked a 14 year old.
Right?
I don't know how he,
I don't know if it was a way to whatever it was,
and I was like,
Yo,
that was a fucking kid you just
knocked out.
He was like,
Yo,
anybody in the rink or fucking get it?
He was Yo.
He was putting kids in with them.
I don't know.
He never,
I saw the video.
He never wanted me to talk about it.
Whatever.
I used to bust his balls about it.
I could tell.
I could tell being around him did he legitimately knew how to fight?
Yeah.
The way he carries himself,
he just had deco,
that scowl.
He just looks like that buddy was the one of the nicest guys,
man.
He was so fun to be around like in not knowing him at all and then traveled with
him for 22 days.
We had so much fun man stories all just laughing and silly and super friendly
and all you wanted to do was man,
just have a,
have a good time.
Yup.
That's all.
He wanted to talk shit,
talk shit to me all the time and was so happy to be able to do stand up.
That was a big thing for him that he could do stand up and travel.
Always tell him.
I tell him all the time,
I said,
I birth your career dude.
I bullied them into the shit.
That's hilarious.
But he did it.
But you could tell,
you could tell and I've been around him and I'd been around his family
and you could tell when he was growing up,
he was the guy that always
had the center of attention.
You could just tell it.
Yeah,
you could tell he knows how to hold a story as he does.
That was a hard one.
Man,
when he,
when he passed I was like,
Whoa,
I didn't know he was sick.
I had no idea.
You know,
it's interesting
that you say that because I had to continue to do shows,
do radio interviews and stuff and the thing that people kept saying was he was
so young,
he was so young and he was young.
But um,
I don't believe that we're all going to live to be 80 90 a hundred.
You know,
only thing we all guaranteed when we're born,
we have are born date.
We have that dash in the middle and then we have the end and it comes down to
what the fuck do you do with your dash?
How,
how hard did you live?
What did you go for?
What inspires you?
What motivates you?
What did you do with that dash?
Who the fuck gives a fuck about living to a hundred and you don't have a
passport.
You haven't been outside of your block.
You haven't been,
you have never been on an airplane.
What are you doing with your life?
And I know Charlie from the point of being in the navy to a band with his
brother sent his brother,
reached certain hightest success,
being interested about interested in the business but you know,
Kinda India but never really major mark.
And then you get a platform that you become and get your identity and shit.
That's the dopest shit.
Yes.
It's one of the best kind of success stories because it doesn't happen
automatically
notch.
And I did it my way and it's like,
you know,
people say what they want to say,
but he put the work in that.
I remember when,
um,
I think the movie Eddie did called Norbit right.
And it came
from a joke.
Charlie had just start over that movie and I guess,
I think him,
and it was talking whatever and dense,
you know how like,
oh,
that could be public,
but it could be movie the Charlie compensate say,
Yo man,
Hankins moved here.
I said,
what you believe?
What you about to do?
He said,
I'm about to go lock myself in a hotel for 30 days and write this motherfucker
movie.
They already gave me the money.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm talking about,
I'm not talking about somebody,
I've been writing this movie for six months,
whatever.
It's like I'm about to go block everything off and write this shit and no matter
what anybody wanted to say about how good the movie was,
what the critics say,
anybody in his business,
if you can do something where it goes from a thought and it goes to the paper
and you can execute it,
how many motherfuckers can do that?
They don't do that.
People talk shit all the motherfucking time,
but then you say,
how many have you got any can yo,
I'm right movies,
give me a script.
Oh,
hold on,
hold on.
I'm almost 30 pages in.
You know what I'm saying?
How many times you have that story?
I got it.
I got a great idea.
All right,
what is it?
I remember I was just with Chappelle show was popping and ludicrous gave me a
lesson out of nowhere.
I saw many airport and I was on Ashy,
Larry Hart.
I was I rich bitch man.
So I'm like rappers,
like we're even right.
So neurohacker is called the amp.
I was like,
Yo Luda right.
He said,
what's up Ashley?
I said,
I said Yo,
kill a motherfucker getting a movie or something cause I just got,
that's what you do.
You just add some motherfucking getting again.
I like it a month I get a movie or something and he looked at me,
Joe,
it was so cold.
He looked me right in my face.
He said,
we look at for people with ideas and I looked to him like,
well I have none.
Right?
So
I guess this is this conversation and it did.
And when I'm telling you it was a lesson,
how the fuck you want to ask with somebody for something and you don't got shit
to give them but you're just a lot of guys in the beginning.
Think that's how you do it.
That's how he do it.
When I was on HBO is the wires,
Motherfucker told me one time,
he said,
Yo d can you give me the number to the wire?
I think I could do this shit.
This motherfucker what the day was like a hotline from anybody from the streets.
You ever thought about being an actor?
You don't want to put those 10 years of getting rejected.
Just call this number and we'll put you on the wire.
You know what gets me about acting though is when someone has never acted
before,
it goes in there and kills it.
You know,
like people who are like athletes in particular,
like rappers have done it.
Like a lot of people have done it,
but some people,
but some people I believe that that,
do you have natural talents?
I think some people have natural talents that person,
like you have a person that's trained that you have people that are natural and
did it.
If you think about it,
acting as just,
uh,
it's uh,
playing make believe so his playmate play
make believe better.
Is it a person that,
is it a person that two foot of 12 years they'd been studying and they went to
the school or as a motherfucker to get a one store and that one character that
they can nail,
right?
Or is it a case of there's some people that'll do stop stand up comedy for 30
years and they're never going to be that funny.
Or Dave could do it for a year and and kill you like Chapelle yeah,
Oh yeah.
He could kill.
But he's gotten,
he doesn't do this.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like there's some people that there's is a whole different animal.
And the reason why I say that,
you're a great comic.
I consider myself a great comic.
You,
I consider you a great comment.
I appreciate it.
And with that said,
like out,
we do have equals like as much as people talk about somebody and you're smiling,
you're like,
I'm great to a motherfucker.
But,
and I was like,
and I,
one day I was watching Dave on stage and I'm like,
what makes this motherfucker great?
And I think in my opinion,
what makes them great?
Cause it's like,
it's not too often that we have or opportunity to have a Muhammad Ali moment.
And when I say that me in a moment where you got to throw everything on the
table,
it's your integrity,
your moral beliefs.
What do I want to stand on,
what do I want to stand for?
And that's how some people get attached.
You.
Of course Muhammad Ali was the greatest,
but it wasn't just in a boxing ring.
We made them great is what he stood for.
And I think when I look at Dave Chappelle and looking to stand up and I look at
his career and I say what made them great?
And that's,
and that's a person just stem.
They believe it's going to give you their unfiltered truth and they own it and
don't compromise and don't back down to anyone.
Well he knows,
he understands what's important about standup,
especially the type of standup that he does.
He asks me to voice full freedom.
Yup.
That's how you,
you asked,
I've heard you say shit on stage.
I'm like that why blood must can fight
soon.
White Dude.
What the fuck just happened?
That mother fucker got some Suplex,
you know,
he not have hit you like,
like in a certain part of your neck and your whole shit is fucked up,
you know?
But those are people only.
I Tony,
I was telling Tony Hinchcliffe.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was Dornish joke about,
uh,
what's the current motherfucking pedophile dude?
Oh,
Jared from subway.
Not Jeffrey said we're just going to chill with my chair now.
He got another other ton of Fab motherfucker.
Another one,
another one.
He's a big actor,
a big time actor.
He,
Oh,
a spacey comes to back off at the bar.
Dude.
Kevin Spacey.
Tawny.
It's crazy debit.
And you know,
if for me that bit is so dope.
I'm like this,
I'm about to throw up.
it's like this.
He won't stop.
Yes.
And I told him,
it was just,
like I said,
I don't know if there's a movement,
but I felt like I was recruiting for gang.
Right.
I saw him in the hallway.
I was like,
yeah,
me and Dave Chappelle
of just talking about the brand of comedy that you have doles it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like state stay true to it because as much as people fuck with us,
they don't want you to say this one.
Say that again.
It's a handful of mufflers on state.
They're going to stay to their truth and they're going to be rewarded for that
shit because the other shit is just bullshit,
man.
I kind of,
I tell you what,
how to fucking,
somebody's going to tell you what you think is funny as a comedian and you know
you don't even know if you think it's funny while you're doing it on stage,
you're trying to make it funny.
So there's a lot of stuff that people here,
maybe they only hear one.
No,
it's funny.
You know what?
It's funny.
You just don't know where.
The funny is sometimes the rhythm of it because I know you,
I don't know what your writing process,
but what's yours.
Mine is like,
it's a regular conversation.
Like I have conversations with friends all day.
It's talking about pop.
I mean topical stuff and it's like,
you know,
people with a sense of humor is like,
you see the funny side,
anything like the digestive smiley,
it's Bill Cosby,
small,
let,
whatever the fuck,
whatever it is to all that shit.
You think I'm funny.
So I never tried to sit down and like I'm a right,
just perfect joke.
It's usually something that comes into casual conversation and it's those
moments,
you know,
you're talking to somebody,
you'd be like,
oh,
that's funny.
Usually that's where I started my writing.
If something connects with me like that and I just go and,
and bill and believe in it and just forced that shit to work.
Yeah.
Once you get on that stage with that idea and you're,
you're in that moment and you have just like a member,
you know,
everybody understands the first time you're trying a new bit.
That's one of the weirdest moments ever.
Everybody don't take the chance.
That's one thing I say about you.
The Times I've watched you that I called him pussy comics,
you know,
muffins is just do a set like,
Yo,
I'm fucked somebody after this shit.
Right.
I'm just gonna stay on outside of here.
Good set.
Then you got the muffled.
It's like,
no.
That was the thought from last week.
I got some more shit to talk about.
I've got some more shit and you and you push those.
Push those bounds boundaries.
A lot of people don't do that shit.
You have to,
it's the robot
robot.
Motherfuckers talk to me.
Yo deal.
Motherfuckers dead could.
You could go to sleep and you wake up and you can Indesit patty here.
We know it worked by the fuck.
Oh No.
Here it goes by closer.
You really want to test about fucking nuts.
Open with your punk has closed a motherfucker over which are closer and we'll
see how much stripped them other motherfucker that flip that shit up too.
Motherfucker.
I call them the pumps.
Yes.
Peru.
They,
they got scared and then they got better.
They got an act and then they got scared again.
Never got rid of that act and then they can stand for the right motherfucker.
Be in a room is to have a buffet like this.
Oh,
that's what you did,
Bro.
Guess what I'm doing?
I'm a flip a whole new set on your mother.
Maybe I want him to do a set,
maybe I'll just build some shit from this one motherfucker.
Right,
right.
Not
that a riff like your pants so tight,
but pull something from him.
If this turns into a whole shit,
it didn't,
that hard drive starts coming.
Cause you know we got millions of jokes that we never use.
They just get stored on hard.
Yes.
They liked this people like just is that your first time?
What'd you come over debt 15 years ago.
But the moment was now,
yeah,
it's going to go now,
you know?
Yeah.
And that's it.
I'm going to tell you,
I've been doing it for 25 years and after 25 years I can honestly slate say I
feel like I get better every year.
Me Too.
And that's the same thing.
That's somebody that's a appears.
Yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
And I think that uh,
I mean good sets and bad sets when you working on new stuff.
But I think overall when I'm done after two years,
each two years is better than the two years before.
But I'm ready to film.
Yeah,
I think that's what it's all about.
It's it's,
man,
if you're not out there,
if you're not out there creating a type material where it's old too,
like I'm gonna do another special who are doing it for,
here's the tricky part.
I'm not on,
I might be on Netflix radar,
but I don't have a deal with them,
but
I'm going to,
not by myself,
but
Dave Chappelle has gave me a verbal commitment that he's going to produce my
next special.
Oh Dang.
So
with that said,
okay,
I don't have a home,
but I'm pretty sure the lel been operating.
We must stand up,
you know when you're ready.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like I just know it,
Bruh.
I just not,
I think the energy that I bring to a special right now and then the energy that
he would bring to produce the,
for me,
it would just fucking blow up.
And this is not something like,
I'm not calling Dave up everyday.
Like,
dude,
you got to do my special.
Every time I'd worked with him,
he was like,
you gotta let me do your best.
I'm like,
let's go motherfucker.
Yeah.
So I feel good about dad.
I don't,
I'm not saying that am I in this place and that place.
First thing I want to do is Dropbox.
I put an hour of material that when it plays,
it could change my life.
I've been seeing you at the store,
man.
You're locked in.
You can tell.
You're doing a lot of sets.
You got Yo Yo,
I want reps.
Yeah.
What do you do?
Brock can fuck a stay home for reps.
Reps can never catch a motherfucker off.
God.
Yeah.
I sometimes I'll do four sets a night in La.
I did,
I did.
And I was so proud of myself.
I got six sets in,
in a night in La and I was so fucking happy because that's a normal night in New
York.
But in la you got to plan that shit.
Yeah,
you got to hit,
you got to hit sunset.
It's guy,
but I boom,
I'm out.
But you feel like you like
you just can do whatever you want cause then you,
you know,
have you starting off with some new on a first one you got four more botana
night is over.
You got them on the phone.
Yes.
When you do an reps the same night too,
when you hit that third set,
it's almost like you're in this weird flow state where there's no resistance
between you and the ideas.
The material just comes out so loose and then you'd know that they need got to
do is one thing to have a joke.
Anybody?
Can anybody mother write a joke and that's why you see some of others you could.
You just tell it.
They dear good writer but it's nothing.
There's no performance of it.
You'd have to say there's no performance that brings you back to brewer.
Brewer wasn't just like funny writing.
He would get physically stretches neck out.
He would go,
shit
man,
I'm telling you the Boston comedy club years ago,
Barry Katz ran and owned it at a time and that was the premiere it showcase bow.
It's a great,
that was,
it was running neck and neck with the comedy cellar kind of seller had the
longest legs.
You know,
it's the tortoise and the hare has been forever,
but this spot and it was,
it was Jim brewer.
It was on John Brown and a brown brown boy.
Johnny's Yay.
Yeah,
it was two guys.
What is it and round boy something fat Johnny and round boy.
Yeah.
They would demolish.
Yup.
Some idea.
And then you had a motherfucker,
17 year old round guy.
Ciao.
One of them.
I don't have any child in the round guy.
They all dance now.
Yeah,
but I'll get the name.
That was a time where comedy was on fire and Jim Brewer would demolish it.
Jay Moore used to demolish it.
It was a great spot.
Is One of those a real small clubs?
Like what did that seat could probably 120 530 but it was like,
it was,
oh,
comedy club Vibe,
brick wall tightness.
You know what I'm saying?
That it reminds you of like Red Johnny and the Round Guy,
right?
Is that it reminds you read Johnny.
Look at Jon Stewart.
Oh look at those guys.
They were on TV.
They were a team.
They got an a pants we had on earth
more pathetic.
You know who I used to follow at the comedy store that that also changed my
life.
Martin Lawrence and the nineties people for God.
You came by him in the nineties Dude Martin used to be the guy who had to go on
after him.
Mitzi used to always stick me on after Martin and I know he was an animal that
I'm going to tell you the first time I saw Martin Lawrence and it was kind of
maybe
interested in comedy.
I was in DC,
I was laying up in the bed with this chick and HBO.
Hbo
was like,
Yo,
you just have popcorn.
Yeah.
So Martin Lewis came.
I did.
It was like ladies and Jim give given up for Martin Lawrence and he says,
look,
black to big ass is skinny motherfucker with all this energy and this
motherfucker open in La.
He said,
give it up for a brother making money the right way.
well,
you make them money the right way.
You could tell your lady shit like shut the fuck up.
I woke up,
I was with a peer,
like,
who is this motherfucker?
Right?
He said,
he said,
you could tell you ladies,
shall I shut the fuck up?
He was like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Did he say,
and he said after that he said,
and she'll shut up too.
He a,
she'll be like,
you so
crazy.
Like who has
come on son the first sentence you like,
like boom.
Yeah.
And he ripped that shit and if you was fucking with that shit,
it was like,
it was everything then it was a good time.
He was going on stage with leather jumpsuits on and I was going on after him.
It was devastating.
Well,
you know,
you already got to make it or made it.
If you're going on with Lebron jumpsuits and you hadn't come the quality,
it was just people were getting up in droves by the time I would go on stage.
Everybody just wanted out of that.
Was that that was,
and this is what I will say that what year was at 90 [inaudible] 94 that was,
that was when that would,
that's when specials were really special.
Right.
There was that many of them.
That's when it was,
there wasn't that many of you had one HBO was it?
Yeah,
HBO was it.
And that was one of those specials where like,
that's what I'm saying with the next one I do,
you never can plan stuff like that,
but the image I want to have as an ng at and that it's like,
this is going to change my life.
And that was the energy and that's why you're so crazy.
You could just fill it.
I can imagine when he was done with that,
everybody can't have like,
just,
you know,
your life is about to change,
like,
yeah.
Uh,
Bernie Mac.
Yeah.
With iron skid.
You motherfuckers,
yeah.
I'm a story about that all time classic.
That's,
you know,
the story behind it.
Oh,
the story behind it,
it was just comic from DC and a Bush burns butts.
Brennan was the DC legend.
Right.
He was a senior guy.
If all of us in DC,
Tony Woods and,
and little Joe [inaudible],
he was,
he was a senior guy.
So a def jam.
Nobody really knew what def jam was going to be.
It was just a new show.
So Butch Burns had a set and he didn't do well.
He bombed like throwing chicken bones.
I'm not saying this because it was black.
What he's,
I'm just saying they was all bottles on a stage.
They booed the shit out of this dude.
Martin couldn't contain or audience.
Martin couldn't do anything.
It was just one of the things.
You have us in a room just so fucked up that kit.
Anybody do anything and only thing you were saying something.
Okay,
just let me go on.
So Butch Burns,
Korea was dead.
He's leaving,
going up backstage and he's talked to Bernie Mac.
Bernie Mexican.
Listen,
hold your head up.
He said,
the sun's not shining on you today,
but just shine on you again.
Just hold your head up.
You'll be all right.
And next on deck with Bernie Mac with the audience that was uncontrollable.
Martin.
Couldn't do anything.
It was just like this Nigga you your own.
Right.
It was one of the moments and that's where the phrase I ain't scared of you
motherfuckers came from that wasn't in his set.
It was a real motherfucking comic.
Figuring out what is going to do on his moment and each had the head Kimmy here
this,
let me hear this.
Give me some vile.
I come in.
Hello.
Foolish.
No give get it from the beginning.
Hi.
Scare you motherfucker.
I'm telling daisy had a you motherfuckers.
All right,
stop it.
Can you pause for a second?
But now this is after her mother fuckers.
Korea was buried.
This is after a Bernie Mac.
He came on a year before that and I think he thought he was dressed too.
Oh yeah,
like a Steve Harvey suit on.
So he wanted to appeal to youth a little bit more.
That's why he got the graffiti thing and he's backstage saying like this could
change my career and other motherfuckers career is over and this is a real
comedian.
This first line out the motherfucking box.
I scared of you mother fuckers,
the motherfucking press.
I ain't coming home.
The foolishness and New York get dumb.
Y'All motherfucking woman look good.
You're like a bigger big salads look good.
But I love sex.
I love Kinky Shit Phase Board.
No.
[inaudible]
yeah,
we gotta get it kicked off Youtube if we keep playing it.
Oh the when we first get down,
when he first stood up,
well you don't want to say it.
He called back.
Oh Man.
They'll use CD motion of it.
Yeah.
It was like damn,
I'm good guarantee the energy he wanted to have to rip was there.
But the story,
the backstory,
it being in that moment and at the end of the day who are going to be prepared
for those moments though?
Motherfuckers Matt Bill for that Shit no more.
You gotta do reps.
You got to do Rep.
They not bill Ford.
They got a mother fucking excuse for everything.
You ever go to motherfucker room Roman.
They'd be talking about how's the crowd motherfucker.
Fuck the crowd.
How are you?
Oh,
that was a crowd leave.
No,
you were laying bro.
It ain't day job is out.
Motherfucking job.
I going hard in the paint.
No,
I'm just saying it's our fucking job.
You're right.
And I've heard you in your podcast talk about no excuses.
I feel like the things you said about,
no,
it's,
yeah,
it's easy to make an excuse,
but in in a day,
it's an excuse.
Yeah.
You got to excuses.
You got a good excuse and you got to bags.
Well,
you know what?
You could have an explanation for failure with no excuse.
What do you mean?
We can talk about how you failed and why you failed.
Don't have an excuse because I fucked up.
I came out,
I was flat.
I didn't turn up.
I fucked up and don't,
and don't use it.
Like I said,
this crowd sucked.
That's the wrong way to look at anytime.
I at all.
See how were they know I ain't never seen it.
How were you?
Yeah,
because guess what?
We don't know what's going to happen,
bro.
We don't know if that motherfucker in the front row is taking about a funeral.
We don't know that,
but it's our job to like,
you know,
kind of going back to me say earlier in a sense we do.
We read people's minds through their body.
You can tell,
you can watch show.
You could be like,
oh,
she was so upset because I said that you could just look at,
you know,
you know the pasture,
you know everything and then we feed off of that.
But who's going to be fucking ready for that?
And there's so many of these motherfuckers that are taught and I'm not going
off,
but it just,
yeah,
it's just frustrating when you see motherfuckers out here making excuses.
Well it's not
good for everybody that's around them.
That's also part of the problem.
See,
when a guy like you is around me or a,
you know,
a guy like Tony Hinchcliffe are people who are just going forward,
who live in the comedy life.
Like you're writing,
you're always writing new material.
That's an empowering.
I want to be around you.
I want to talk
and be around a motherfucker to talk.
But I've been around motherfuckers that got more bomb material.
Did they got real material?
You don't.
Mother's got a old ditch do.
I did my bomb set and they're waiting to just one job,
don't work.
And be like,
oh it didn't slide it to their bomb is shit.
They bomb set.
Don't have no bomb material.
Who the fuck writes material?
The bomb man yo it case they throw tomatoes.
I got the old tomato bid,
my uncle grew tomatoes back.
That's why they're staggered to hurt me.
Go hard or go home.
That's a ridiculous idea to have a set that you do and the audience is shitty.
I mean you do what you do.
You know we got,
you got search shit.
If some come your way you could bounce off but I'm talking of these
motherfuckers is actually right
in the event that I bomb is going to go that way.
They're bombing bits and I,
I just like,
I'm a person that just loves doing it,
love getting better and I tell people all the time,
if you like any of the things that I've done where there was the HBO is the wire
Chappelle show on other stuff.
If you come see me do stand up,
you'll become a complete fan.
Cause like you said earlier,
that's the one thing that we control.
We don't have to have an audition for that shit.
We don't have to motherfucking get tested for it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
oh,
I made it to this test.
We don't have to fucking,
we don't have to pitch it and you know it's a good thing and they say fuck you
anyway.
You can't fuck with us with that.
It's like that's what we,
our executive producer to producer,
we the the line producer,
we everything and you can't do it.
It's us and a motherfucking mic and at the end of the day,
no matter what success I feel Joe,
we get with this whatever level,
I mean your biggest shit,
you,
you hit it.
You know,
whether it's TV or,
or,
or movies,
nothing is going to ever be able to take away from you being a flat month flat
footed motherfucker.
Thank you.
Stay in an audience and you've built your standup name enough where for the most
part,
the rest of your life you'll be able to create a good living off of your name.
Off of doing stand up.
Yeah.
Hollywood don't have to call.
Yeah,
that's,
that's big too,
but if you respect what it is that you have a relationship with those people,
you have to write for them.
You have to work on your stuff.
You have to be diligent.
You have to be,
you have to have an ethic about it.
Yeah.
You don't want to rip anybody off.
You want them to see a great show.
You want to do your best.
I feel,
and it's so weird.
You know how we are.
I could do it.
I could do a show comedy clubs,
like 500 people,
motherfuckers.
I'm destroyed in his two motherfuckers not filling me and I need to get their
undivided teach.
It's like,
I don't even hear the laughter.
I'm like,
you don't fucking like me now.
Let's talk about it.
You know,
it was the worst at that was nick depalo.
Well,
he'll go at one person,
it's like this and the whole rest of the audience is dying.
It's,
someone's given an the stink eye.
He's like,
what's your fucking problem?
Yeah,
you can't.
You just like that.
And it's like you and you won't stop until that person doesn't have a problem
with a or a leaf.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing,
man.
And just got undivided attention.
You get committed to wanting everybody to love you.
You can't,
that's impossible.
There's also people that will fuck with you for extra attention.
They want you to look at them,
their arms crossed because they need attention.
They're the same people that protest shit where it doesn't really necessarily
make sense to spend so much time and effort thinking about these things.
Let me tell you something.
It's so funny you said about protest because
MMM,
last couple of years,
calm has been interesting as a lot of people that are fans of Donald Trump.
A lot of people that aren't fans of Donald Trump.
And I think it's petty for you to be upset with anybody because he chose to vote
for whoever they chose to vote for.
I think it's stupid shit.
But I will say this past election was interesting in the sense that a lot of
people were upset.
Black people were upset the last election.
Uh,
women were upset.
Gay people were upset,
but white people were really upset.
Like white people were the angriest and white people did not protest.
They voted black people.
It's like black lives matter white people.
It's like we'll see about that in the morning and when ever you hear someone
says,
we'll see about that in the morning.
It's going to be some change.
But comedy,
I don't think kindness should be a place where people exercise anger or be
angry.
How so?
In what way?
Good.
Um,
like p and met like when Donald Trump first got elected,
you know,
personally like it,
it was very interesting and I seen a lot of comments.
They can just go up there and be like,
Fuck Donald Trump and just ah,
you know,
you could find a way to say fuck Donald Trump or anybody.
But it doesn't have to be fueled with any anger.
You know what I'm saying?
It doesn't have to be fueled.
Like fuck,
you'd be like this.
Fuck them.
Okay.
Why,
why do you say that?
Why do you say fuck it?
And then loud the reason.
But I just don't think that people should be angry about how do you feel about
just,
I think it's fucked up when politics meet people
angry.
It's part,
it's contrary to what you were saying was great about Chappelle show that the
comedy came without being angry,
but it made great points,
but even anybody on both sides could laugh at it.
Yeah.
The thing about Trump that's,
it's interesting.
It's like the job shouldn't exist.
The job of web president.
Yes,
she shouldn't exist.
It's a ridiculous idea to have 300 million people under the guidance of one.
That's insane.
And that one's,
that one wins in a popularity contest.
That's insane.
Right?
It's fucking insane.
It doesn't make sense.
It was a,
it was a great idea back when they were pilgrims and it was a small colony and
they just came over on a boat,
forget it.
Forget about the rest of this shit.
This is too many humans.
So when you let a guy like that,
like try to be president,
no,
he,
you're not going to be happy.
No one's going to be happy,
but you're not going to be happy if anybody wins.
It's,
it's,
it's untenable.
Look at Obama,
Obama aged like how many of years in eight years he looked at Ge,
he age 20 the altered to Ted Danson effect once.
Cheers.
Got Counseling you.
Who the fuck is that?
Yo,
the first time you saw Ted desert,
I'm not talking about years after chairs like after Fred,
you're like God damn stopped dying his hair.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Is there something about Trump before that that people enjoyed that he was in a
lot of rap lyrics meant he was like the ultimate,
like people would probably still be if he was a is to have resident,
right.
It'd be different.
He still popular.
People wrapped up.
They liked the lifestyle.
But the thing was to just my thoughts.
The thing was because you thought
you knew a person,
you thought you norm.
And even when he got elected,
I think a lot of people thought they knew him,
right?
They thought they knew him.
They thought the image.
Like you're going to be a billion guy.
Billion dollar playboy.
Gaf ever.
But you thought you knew him,
but then when you got to know him,
you start to think,
well,
maybe I didn't know him when you got to see him as president,
I don't think even as an even as much as even how he got elected,
people were upset about it,
but I think a lot of people,
somebody was like,
you know where it may be.
All of their shit was just to get elected.
Maybe that energy was to get elected and if that was the case that he'd mastered
it,
he'd mastered how to get connect with his base.
He Massad met.
He mastered how to get,
not everybody the fuck would you put just the right amount of people?
Yeah,
it looked the numbers.
It wasn't about them.
It was a popularity contest,
but it's also new.
Like these are the people that got hit and he figured that out.
What the something?
At some point Joe,
people were like,
hi,
oh,
it's over now.
Let's see who you really are.
And I think it's so many examples of when you felt like he could showed people
example,
example that he's fought.
Everybody opposed the judge just as base.
Right?
And I think that's what get people ladder.
What make people frustrated.
He gives impression that,
you know,
I only care about these people that elected me.
You won.
Right?
But do you have responsibility to everybody?
And it's just don't have that felon.
Even on my social media,
I don't go hard.
I keep it kind of neutral.
But I said something and somebody said,
well,
the last time I checked Darnell,
the economy was doing well.
And I said,
ah,
you can't confuse the economy with humanity.
And that's the thing.
And that's what,
that's what people don't feel good about.
You can tout all the numbers,
you could talk all the numbers,
you want a black unemployment,
all the numbers,
all the numbers.
But how do people feel?
You know what I'm saying,
representative,
they don't feel,
don't,
they don't feel represented.
Don't,
they don't feel like I can rock either way,
but I'd Democrat,
Republican,
I make enough money where a lot of the views of Republicans,
but like,
Yo,
that's right up my alley.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you got there,
right.
I'm rich,
you know,
like damn,
I fucked a Republican pitches before us,
you know,
I'm saying,
you know what I'm saying?
But at same time,
it's the,
and it may not sound right to a lot of people,
but it's the human factor of it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you want to feel good,
right.
You want to,
you why so many people don't know the economy is doing well because they don't
feel good.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
You want to celebrate,
you want to cheer,
you want to feel good about it.
And that's the whole thing.
Anything.
I believe when Obama ran his campaign was change.
Donald Trump's would make American great again.
Either one of them could have ran off each other's campaign slogan.
Do you know after Bush Obama could have said make American great again and it
would electrify to debase the same as change.
True.
They said the same fucking thing.
That would be a great thing for Obama.
And I'm gonna tell you one thing that kind of,
I don't insulting or we get,
people have said,
it's like you keep pushing in narrative,
make America great again,
make America great again.
You keep pushing it as if America was so fucked up before you took office.
And that's not the case.
Right?
Like when,
when,
when Obama took it from Bush,
he was making America great again.
You're talking about a shit show and the thing that people were,
however you took it,
respected or not,
it was never nothing.
Lace would and it was never,
it wasn't no,
Yo,
you see this mess.
Bush left me.
It was never like,
oh this motherfucker,
it was never,
no mentioned to see a new movie about Bush.
I didn't see it either.
What's it called?
Jamie?
Is it out the one with vice,
but Dick Cheney and George Bush or whenever I think about,
I say about the movie about getting shot in the face because that's the only
thing that I want to say.
Well the,
the,
the thing about Bush and Cheney is like that movie kind of makes it seem like
Cheney was the guy pulling the strings and Bush was just like simple,
happy go lucky guy who they just roped into being president because he was the
son of a president.
That's that far fetched though.
It's not far fetched at all.
It's not at all.
Not even remotely.
I think I actually agree with it,
but I think about Bush now.
I don't think about them in a negative way,
but I think about changing in a negative way.
Yeah.
It,
I think about Halliburton,
I think about all the,
the rebuilding of the places that we blew up,
like all the crazy shit on Dick Cheney come from picture no bid contracts that
are worth billions of dollars to
the bush.
Because if I ha,
I know it may sound crazy.
If I had to have a pick of who I would want,
wanted to be the Republican candidate.
It was on the,
on the Republican side was on.
I like Jeb Bush.
I didn't really get to know him at all.
That's it.
That was something that I don't know,
I don't know too much about,
but I just,
I just thought that he had,
he was like Kinda like a mama's boy.
I think he probably out of all the kids,
I probably think that he probably was the one that thought a little outside of
what their normal,
I think he was a successful businessman and mainly Latino chicken,
if I'm not mistaken.
I know nothing about them,
but I just,
I don't know,
but,
but Bush Trump fucked him up.
Like,
how do you fuck motherfuckers up with just nicknames?
Wander,
laid down,
fell like jab wanted to lay down.
I really do.
I felt like you didn't want that Trump put all the motherfuckers days like you
were saving till you got your nickname.
Yeah.
Once you got lion,
you know that motherfucker like they rap artists.
Yeah.
No,
it was a smart thing.
He did that no one's ever done before.
Nobody.
A lot of things.
And even like,
even when I'm,
even when,
when Obama got elected,
you know what it got a Bama elected was fucking Facebook and $5 contributions,
$5 donations.
He was when he was,
when,
when Obama was running that he was the first person to use Facebook the way he
did.
Really?
Oh Man,
I have so many every goddamn day.
It was Obama acts,
but he wouldn't ask for like millions.
He would just like,
like a dude in the hood.
You're let me hold fat.
Arlis right?
Like I would get an email,
hey,
this is Barack Obama,
Yo,
let me hold $10 right?
And I got,
and I was like,
yeah,
he got $10 right?
And then a week later he asked for fucking $20 and then he asked for 10 again,
and then it got so bad.
Then Michelle was sent me an email,
but he just,
he'd nickeled and dimed America.
And that's what supported his campaign.
And the fact that he was at a right at the turn of,
of,
uh,
of form of media that you can use to your advantage.
He was the Facebook guy.
He reached people.
The Facebook,
Donald Trump's doing the same thing through Twitter.
I can reach people.
Why does he tweet so much?
Why does he tweet so much everyday?
Cause he knows motherfuckers would rather pick up a phone every to treat.
Didn't read a newspaper 100%.
Fuck them.
All I need is headlines.
Way more people reading tweets versus newspapers.
Right.
Every stunned.
Like if you could get to see the exact engagement in a good article in the New
York Times on the front page versus one of Donald Trump's tweets.
Like nobody.
The only two people that motherfuckers are just waiting for their tweets come as
Donald Trump to Kanye west.
Yeah.
Those are the two most interesting tweet people.
Kanye west could just say grapefruit juice and fuck up all of the media the next
day.
What do you think he meant?
Do you think he meant it was hungry or he was thirsty?
Can you just tweet it?
Grapefruit juice,
one of the most,
one of the most interesting tweeters out there.
You wait for a Kanye West tweet while he's kind of a free way of expressing
himself.
Here's an unfiltered way of expressing myself and a lot of people,
um,
people have mixed feelings about it.
It's views and the black community is a little stressed out right now.
Well,
because of his Trump thing.
But you know what,
uh,
I don't know how much of that is to,
there's two things.
One Obama called MC jackass that could weigh on you.
That stung a little bit,
you know,
and then Obama,
when Obama has gone and Trump takes office,
Trump has willing to let him talk,
but Trump's Trump,
Trump old charm him.
Here's the thing,
Joe,
with that said,
like when I do white clubs,
black clubs,
whatever,
do all type of clubs.
But the thing is,
um,
you,
you first off,
Kanye West has a voice,
not too many.
As much as black people want to throw the towel in on him.
We don't have too many voices that everybody is waiting to hear whether whatever
comes out,
he has a voice.
I believe that Kanye West is trying to say something.
I just don't know what the fuck he's trying to say because I'm not fluent in
easy,
barely know Swahili.
I can do something easy and I think he's trying to say something.
But if there was some type of interpreter,
you know,
this would be a dope.
If the Chappelle show was right now this would be a dope ass kid.
Kanye West says something.
It did.
Dave Chappelle,
is this conscious to interpreter?
That would be hilarious.
He does.
Connie says it didn't.
Dave yells up.
You know what I think,
and this is men only talk to him once on the phone.
But what I think from studying them and pay attention,
because we're supposed to eventually do a podcast one day is I think he's uh,
he's thinks different.
He does.
He connects dots different.
And that's one of the reasons why he's so prolific with music.
That's what I'm the point.
I'm making jokes and that's the point.
What I'm saying?
Not speaking easy,
but here's what some people that think like that,
they don't know how to get it out.
It's like just to speak it,
but I have been thinking about you.
I love you.
You're my dad.
You must area here.
My Dad.
You're like my father.
You know how hard that was for the black community here?
Fuck.
You could sell them a clean all you want,
but what you're saying you'd like my father.
It didn't black people sitting back like,
could you please explain that?
So with the,
then this was funny to me.
They kind of said,
yeah,
you're like,
like father figure to me like when I was younger I thought he was Korea hit me,
we'll do horrific.
You know?
Father was in it in a shootout,
a drive by,
if this will fuck me up,
bro.
He said,
yeah.
When I was younger,
my parents
separated at a young age.
First off,
you had parents,
you already winning motherfucker.
None of my niggas ain't beds.
They had my mother and my father.
You know what I'm saying?
Not that,
no.
Okay,
okay.
Cut My friends by her parents may say,
my parents separated.
I mean they were married.
That's two winds
you up to before he be get to and they separated and mom moved down the street.
You still got to see your fucking father.
So that was a little troubling.
But the whole thing is,
I'm pretty sure at some point Kaley West,
we'll be able to speak a language that everybody can understand.
Until then it's only half full of people to speak and understand it.
And
also right here.
But here's my problem with all this and I've been thinking about this a lot.
They want to medicate him,
right?
Yeah.
Look how effective he is.
Just stop.
Just stop and think about culturally effective in terms of the music that he
makes it.
People love his,
his employees.
He creates clothes.
Okay.
He's married his,
he craves conversation and dialogue too.
He does.
His wife makes hundreds of millions of dollars.
They're wealthy,
insanely
successful.
If you want to talk about overall success,
they're together.
They have children's,
they're super wealthy.
He produces incredible art that's loved worldwide and they want to medicate him.
Just stop and think about how effective,
but they want to medicate what they want to medicate him to operate.
At what level do exactly right.
Think about how effective he is and yet they want us to medication or off off
when he's off medication.
He said himself,
he's his most creative stop and think about how creative he's been.
How successful is,
how well received.
Yeah.
Happy and all these other elements in his life,
but yet they want him to act the way they want him to act and take the hat off.
You know what I'm saying?
Whatever you can say whatever the fuck you what the black wasn't mad cause he
would have had,
they was mad cause it wasn't a fit that was looking for a new era.
If that was a new era,
they would have been more accepting of it.
Man.
We just don't what Dad's side.
It's red and white now that that's a problem.
Anything with red with white letters.
I'm
telling you,
it's like when I see,
it's so funny now.
Whenever I see a red head,
I'm like,
oh,
like I'm immediately after the show upstate New York and it was this white dude
came up to me,
I have to show.
And he didn't have what looked like I'm making American great.
It hit,
he had a make America great again hat and it looked like he had the original
one.
You know how you got to,
you know how you're going to Boston fan and you're like,
you only been a fan.
It was a brand America making be great before.
Like he probably sold the Hashtag [inaudible] they would.
Here's the thing,
Joe,
this is my,
he had the hat on this shit and at the end of the show he was one of the dudes
that was continued to laugh in the most,
you know,
and I went up to him and I,
I was like,
Yo,
I gotta get a picture with you.
And I took the picture.
It was a video.
I was like,
yeah,
motherfucker,
y'all see us head.
He started laughing and we had a good moment.
It wasn't,
no,
I wasn't angry him.
I'm not going to let
think it's hard to get away from it.
But the think Kanya with the hat,
he likes the idea of how it gets people flustered.
They get special was triggered,
right.
One Omar's,
excuse me.
It's all right.
No,
but I'm saying it's like triggered like even,
and I,
when I,
when a guy had the hat on and I was talking to,
I heard an aside,
it was like this,
oh,
he's triggered and I wasn't,
I wasn't triggered by that.
What I was trying,
what I would have been triggered by just how you make me feel with that hot no
period.
Period.
You know,
you can come at me like you could come at me with the head on with some fucked
up energy and I could feel it.
But the energy he gave me was like,
I know this may sound crazy.
We was like,
Yo,
you a funny motherfucker with the hat on.
You're like,
okay,
I didn't give a fuck.
Right.
Because I couldn't let him,
I couldn't let him make me feel like if that's what his intent was,
he's gonna make me feel uncomfortable.
I couldn't do it seemed like he was trying to make you feel and go.
I think he really does.
Who he was.
I think that's who he was,
but I think that's what it was.
But I know that motherfucker laugh like a motherfucker.
So at a comedy club,
that's all you can ask for.
So you could want since all you want.
Yeah.
Now you've got the right perspective band looking at her all the right way.
I love it man.
It's like at the end of the day you got good people and you got bad people and
it's who do you choose to be?
Yeah.
You want to be on the good side of the bed and it's easy man.
It's,
it's,
I know it's a Corny Rodney King Sake.
Can we all just get along?
We all can get along if motherfuckers just remove the hate when you know who I
always look at it,
we can get along.
The three of us in this room,
there have no problems.
So when we people expand out what goes wrong?
Like if something goes wrong when you get to like 3 million,
what is it?
3 million was just humans.
It's people expand out.
You get a couple of people together and most people can be fine together.
Most people,
the vast majority,
it's when you get to large numbers,
it gets fucked up.
It gets fucked up.
It's almost like people are supposed to live in small towns,
you know,
with a bunch of cool like small town with a bunch of assholes would suck small
towns with all.
How about if we lived in a small town with all comedians
right now I would be,
if I live in a small town right now,
I would be a grandfather.
You think so?
100% what do you do in small towns?
You drink and get fucking her babies.
Yeah,
but I mean a small town,
a community,
let me say,
filled with Comedians we were,
there would be a lot of murders.
Young comedians will actually kill each other.
Man,
I can't even like,
I can't eat.
This is only a certain amount of communes that can be around at one time because
it didn't start getting,
you know,
there's motherfuckers jockeying for the best joke bar.
There's some that are like that,
but there's some that lay back and the laughers and this other snipers.
It was a good sniper.
Yeah,
there's,
but they got their breathing pattern.
Right.
They know when you pull that trigger,
he's supposed to shock you.
It posts to site you every time.
Yeah.
They don't throw any loose bombs,
none of that shit.
They got us.
Yeah.
That's a good way for that.
That's a very snipers in the motherfucker grants that go out there.
Squares.
I was military for four years.
We Really?
Yeah.
I said I was,
I was a word.
I was a cop in the military.
Really?
Nobody believes I was at worst cop ever.
I've made one arrest in four years and it was because the girl came through the
gate.
She has some big titties and I decided that I needed to pull her over,
but I was the worst fucking
cock and I had to get out of the military because I used to hear this phrase all
the time,
airman Rollins,
your blatant disregard for established military policy shows a lack of military
brain and integrity.
I here that I was like these muff was going to gun and kicked me out if was four
years.
I was a cop station and coons on Korea station in Boleyn and you SEO tongue
saying NSCO Seo Nuna how you go.
They get talked to Kay Herso.
Wow.
Um,
four years military,
three years to two years in Korea,
two years at Bolling air force base.
And I got out and just randomly went to a comedy club,
became a heckler.
I was an asshole.
I used to go to his comedy club every Wednesday to fuck with the comedians.
Where was it,
Kami connection to greenbelt?
It was like the black comedy club in DC.
This was a time of when Martin Lawrence was on fire to def jam thing was popping
in and they had on black comedy clubs.
It would be,
it would be a pizza shop.
They'll just turn okay now and it's a comedy club.
Monique had a club that she made a turn from a restaurant to a comedy club just
because she got more business on the weekend as a comical Indian restaurant and
it took it over and I used to go heckle the comedians and I,
I was such a good heckler that people used to come to the show to hear me
heckle.
There'll be a door like,
Yo,
is that asshole dude going to be here tonight?
And that was me and the club owner dare me to go on stage because he wanted to
shut me up Java.
So cocky after four weeks of heckling,
I tried to make a deal with the club on it.
Come on,
I swear.
I know,
I'm telling you.
I said,
I know I've increased business by 30%
we did start working on the door there.
He looked at me like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Anybody in DC to tell you this story?
And they wanted me to shut up.
They asked me to go on stage and I went on stage and the first time I went on I
murdered the shit and I knew that I wasn't going to be doing anything else with
my life with doing it.
I just knew him.
It was just like,
fuck,
fuck all like Pat,
Pat,
pat.
How did it feel?
It felt great to remember it.
I remember it because she in your mind,
I remember it because I had talked so much shit to this point.
And the thing about it was,
but th th the room of the energy,
the energy of the room was there because there was a lot of people that came.
They saw me,
they were like ink,
like when you going go with you should,
you know,
they were like,
you should try,
you should try it.
So the first time I went on,
people were excited about it.
They didn't know what to expect and I wrote all these jokes.
I'm like,
I got,
I got 30 minutes.
I was like,
I was so cocky.
We say have an open mic and you know,
Mike List is like 30 people and I would be like 10 on the list and they would
keep bumping me.
And I thought they were just trying to save me the headline.
I didn't think they were just trying to give me the shittiest spot,
but half the club came to see me so they would stay there.
And at first time I went on and all these jokes I planned I was going to do and
when I went on stage I drew a complete blank.
I remember shit.
And then I went without no,
that's,
I start fucking with somebody in the audience.
I got a laugh.
It did.
I did my material and I've,
I didn't know what the light was.
They gave me the light and I was like,
Oh,
I've got a goal.
Like you know the light means just make that your last joke.
Right.
And I got off abruptly.
They ask,
as I said,
I got to go and people started booing,
the host went up and there was,
I know Daniel,
he doesn't know he's new is his first time.
He don't know what to like me.
He'll be like,
he'll be back.
And um,
I was there almost every Wednesday for eight months and then I moved to new
first I moved to New York six months.
Wow.
I said I'm Outta here.
Where'd you go?
First Club was or live?
Either one.
Brooklyn,
New York.
It was a bad barrel.
That's why until it stops.
But Brooke,
it was interesting to me cause I didn't go from from DC to like mainstream white
colors.
I was doing still to kettle rooms and shit.
And a lot of times I couldn't get spots.
So I would go to a,
I will go to the um,
poetry open mikes cause that she used to be so doll,
the water was shifting the wave wave and I'd be like,
is anybody want break for this shit?
Right.
And then I would go do just when I couldn't do conquers,
I will do that until I started making a name for myself and never looked back.
It was dope.
New York is a great place to get your chops up here.
Do you enter New York?
It had to be probably like 95,
probably like 95 giant dirty moved.
I'd gone,
I left in [inaudible] 94 to come to la.
Oh yeah.
When did you get out of here?
I got out here like seven years ago,
maybe eight years ago.
And there was,
because my,
my sister was different because I wasn't getting a lot of roadwork and I was
like,
well fuck,
if I'm not getting lot of roadwork I might as well try to get more film and
television stuff to move out to la.
And then when I moved out here,
I um,
started getting more personal parents.
And so basically I moved to La and became a road comic and I wasn't mad at it
because after you've done it for a while,
you just want to where the fucking I can make money doing this shit.
You know what I'm saying?
If the road is the road,
you know what I mean?
If it's Hollywood,
it's Hollywood.
But who's going to pay me some money and it was the road to now like I do 40
weekends a year,
but with me having a a young kid,
now I'm trying to focus more in film and television and get some more stable
shit cause I'm,
I'm getting a little,
you know,
it's getting burnt.
I hate to say this because I've said it too many times.
[inaudible] she didn't have a podcast.
I've heard the humor man did.
I started a thousand podcasts.
I need to start yours.
I'm with it.
I'm telling you my dude like you should do it.
I used to do and I miss,
I used to do radio.
I did radio.
I did hot 97 but I would love to do a pocket here and natural.
You could have the number one podcast in the country.
No bullshit.
100% let's do anything,
Jamie.
Yeah,
it'd be easy.
You just need someone to make you an account and just up shit.
You could upload it literally from your iPhone or whatever phone you use.
You put a little microphone in the bottom of it.
I do it and another reason why,
because I'll always want to talk.
Yeah,
I'm sure it's fun.
I get it.
But you've been in the game for a while.
Nine years,
almost 10 when you were,
you could see yourself pioneer.
No,
there's people that before made for sure.
I was just one of the early adopters.
I'd say early adopter,
but it was already established.
Adam Curry had one,
I think he's,
he invented the name podcast and then Adam Carolla went from radio to podcast
and that's when I was like,
oh,
I didn't know.
Oh wait a minute.
Was he a radio personality for,
he was doing the man show?
No,
no.
He did the Mancho and they did he,
well he was a radio personality first that he did the man show and I think he
did radio during the same time.
He did love line during the same time.
And then after that he had a big time syndicated morning radio show and I did
his radio show a couple of times.
And then when he left his radio show and went to podcast,
he got this professional studio built and everything and I went to visit him and
I was like,
whoa.
And I remember walking around the place,
come on,
look at this shit.
Like I was like,
I came here,
I said,
who the fuck got a wolf and not a wolf from here?
From London?
Yo.
Oh Shit.
That I'd never seen motherfuckers level.
Like what is that
point?
What does that,
what does that call it right there?
That's an elk elk.
One of the people that,
um,
that,
that make that,
what do they call it?
Profession taxidermy.
But it's only when they put like the fake,
when the herring are over it,
the fake eyeballs.
Is that yours?
That's mine.
Yeah.
That's the actual real skull.
God Damn,
that's what they call a European mount when they just have the skull and the
antlers.
That's where I get my food from cooking.
Uh,
elk roast tonight when I get Outta here and this from him
diet,
that one already,
man.
Shit man.
Hell y'all.
If I should show my boys I'm eating elk,
they'd be like,
you changed.
So I think you gain,
Yo,
he gave his son,
he had cottage cheese the other day.
Look,
say he a Vegan.
Any elk?
Oh No.
Said he tried to do the fucking $5 foot laws with smaller,
smaller.
That poor guy.
I would say ask you this.
How does that go?
Come back.
He doesn't ever know because he,
he's going to,
was he,
how does he feed himself?
The way he feeds itself,
because he's still going to have a base.
The base is what was like the motherfuckers be like,
fuck it.
I would have did the same thing.
Ooh,
that's not a good group.
People,
you said it's not,
it might not be a good group of people the way you think it,
but for him it's a group of people.
Right.
It's going to be still some people that want to hear his side of the story.
Everybody's not,
everybody's not like dismissive of them.
Right.
It's some people still hold on to like,
well maybe some people that just gonna you know like I refuse to believe it.
Point blank.
Well he's still denying it.
He's saying that they're lying.
Yeah man.
But you know,
I don't know.
Maybe on that doesn't look good.
Oh No,
don't do this was in town on now.
I think something else was going on,
Bruh.
I think something did.
I think he was,
I think he was paused.
Me paying him for something else.
Would it be not just
thank you guys.
All right.
I got some other ways we can make money.
I don't know.
Again,
it's just,
sorry.
It's so fucked up bro,
because you have
like,
it's so fucked.
Live up.
My older brother is gay and like with that situation it kind of rung home to me
cause there,
when it first was pronounced like this,
I wish the fuck's in my word.
Try to validate my brother would disrespect my brother.
I know how it arms.
I'd be ready to go.
So I had that and that's what's so fucked about.
Oh Shit.
He has so many people.
There was Ryan for him for different reasons,
man.
And it's like really selfish for you to not give a fuck about how you're going
to hurt people.
You know what I mean?
He,
he didn't realize how bad it would go wrong maybe man,
Bro,
come on.
You go on the gates.
Were you saying when you're,
when you're saying thrawn fuck the bleach on me mag.
You trying to,
you're trying to trigger a motherfucker.
It's checker for Elvis cell.
Did he say he was a gay Tupac?
He said that I ain't no killer,
but don't push me for Vince.
Just like the sweetest joy next to getting,
well he didn't say the positive [inaudible] hilarious.
He said that he was again,
he already had his movie in his head.
That's so irritating.
I fought back.
I'm the K two but he already had his hashtag.
You probably bought the white website trace there at,
and I don't want to start this podcast,
but I gotta pee so bad.
I did two podcasts in a row.
Can Talk to Jamie for just two minutes.
We can talk about what is that?
I'll take one of those.
Is that a pre roll
words back?
I'll be right back of,
I just have to be so bad.
I ain't mad at you son.
Look,
just know you know you la.
I just,
is this an indycar sativa?
There is some extra spice and next year there's a little extra like I think it's
called butter butter.
That why that's like wax.
What?
It's a little bit it.
You can't really tell it to be honest with you.
That's how white boys set up.
No,
just eat half the ear.
You'll be okay.
How many people still come up to you about the wire?
I know that obviously Chappelle show,
but the bond,
the people that come into me a wired,
they'd identify by themselves as instant intellects.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like people in
Hell,
they'll,
it's almost like they're cocky.
Like I know you want Chappelle on a couple other things,
but you know what?
I really love you from the wire.
That was a dope experience.
Did you ever watch HBO is the corner I started,
I started,
I think I got a,
I feel like it was six episodes and I watched you,
it was a six year olds on the ministers.
All of it.
I was in ed.
Okay.
I played a heroin addict and that,
and um,
a lot of people don't know people that are fans.
If you are a fan of the wire,
you definitely been a fan of recording because so many of the actors came back
to after I watched the wire I wanted more and more content like that.
And so I went back and tried to watch it,
but I just,
I actually enjoyed rewatching the wire more.
So I've watched,
I liked to show and I was supposed to,
my character was supposed to um,
build up more.
But uh,
the Baltimore Tourism Board was upset that every time someone goes shooting,
bought somebody depicted as a drug infested pretty much what it is.
So that's why he went from the,
if you notice the shift in the writing,
it went from the towers to the DOC's.
Like,
how the fuck did we get to the docks?
That's cause they didn't just want to be in the hood like that.
But David Simon,
he was um,
he was like,
Yo,
I liked you.
Have you know what you did.
So they brought me back for the last,
for the last season.
I've tried to get Joe to watch it,
but it's,
it's like it's 10 years old now.
So it's,
I get back into an old show,
but it's so good.
So many people list that way.
Like they were like,
definitely why are fanatics and when they brought me back to last season,
I was nervous because HBO the last season of any show on HBO to writers get
vindictive and they do nasty shit to the characters.
Like to last season,
the Oz,
it was dudes getting raped.
An Aza wouldn't even on us.
They was like,
dude,
I'm on Nickelodeon.
I'm just trying to get to the bathroom man.
But they was right to me.
I didn't get raped the last season and it was fun topic.
I know I've got to settle down and choose it for a run.
Yeah.
Get in and it's still,
it's the,
you just got to watch it because it's,
it's so good.
His character comes up at like the best time and he's not to spoiler alert it,
but like the follow the money starts with him and like that's a,
that's why,
you know,
that did my role would have been like if they didn't switch the tone,
if they would've kept it in the towers.
My Shit was cause I was the connection between the streets and the politics.
I know I could have blown I out.
And when I first got busted,
when I was in a room,
I was trying to,
I was getting robbed,
a mansion,
it will tell you Dan.
And he said,
what's your name?
I said,
my name is um,
uh,
data.
Uh,
my name is dayday,
but they mostly call me Damien.
Right.
And then he said,
my name is Daniel.
And they mostly call me lieutenant.
And this is have to had already seen how old robbed a whole Korean because I
thought he was a driver with me.
And that character's should have been off by then.
But so it was a good opportunity.
There was another cool platform.
It was dope.
I can honestly say whatever happens in my career.
I was on two shows.
There are good go down
in television history.
The wires you have,
I believe you about the wire.
I mean everybody says it.
I just had,
I never saddled down and washed it.
But for sure Chappelle show is the greatest sketch comedy.
It's,
it's one number one and number two is like that and in living color.
And you could pick your spot depending upon when you grew up and what it meant
to you.
Because for a lot of people in living color too,
cause it was on Fox,
you didn't have to have cable to get it.
It was on Fox and I have to have cable.
Did you have to understand a Fox Fox was right,
but then it was like,
it was new too because it was for the most part of all black cast,
all black cast.
When you dancers,
dancers,
it was Jennifer Lopez.
Everybody was making money and getting to ask when that was,
don't the wins I think who wasn't shine was Dj.
I don't even think he knew how to Dj.
But Keenan had deaf fucking vision man.
Yeah.
He had that vision.
Who's like the seasons in that go?
Oh No,
probably six.
But they're really go that man.
It was um,
that was the show.
Every comedian hope did,
they will,
every year they would come around and say they're looking for new people for
living color in every city was like just busting doors down and tried to get an
audition.
And I remember watching him for the first time I was at a pool hall and like
Yonkers,
New York and I looked up at the screen and me and a buddy of mine,
my friend Jon Tobin were playing pool and we're watching the show.
I was like,
what in the fuck?
And it was fun to do it.
No lips and fire Marshall.
Bill came out.
I was like,
God,
the fuck John [inaudible] was,
I was animal man.
He was again like once you saw him,
you just start laughing.
Yeah.
He was an animal.
I mean,
how many times,
Eric,
what do we have now?
Homey.
The clown clown homie.
Don't play that.
Girls were always saying,
I'm Paul Mooney on wrote the home in Cloncurry.
Really?
Yup.
It's hilarious.
It was groundbreaking.
It was Wanda.
Wow.
He fights,
but they look at that.
That's funny,
right when talk about how,
nope.
Have a career.
That motherfucker got Jamie foster.
Go for that to Oscar.
That motherfucking could do anything.
He could do anything and sing.
Yeah,
we've talked about it before.
He's got that weird,
he's got that weird ability to do anything.
Like when Mike Tyson was talking about Jamie playing him,
you know he was a,
well,
Jamie welcome.
He's apparently is.
Oh,
I know.
He's going to kill him.
He's going to kill it.
It's going to kill it.
He could do anything.
He can do anything.
He's got great stories,
man.
How'd one of the podcasts are a great,
great story.
He's just a good guy.
Anytime I've ran into any time I've talked to him,
he's always been a really cool dude.
Good Dude,
man.
It's very friendly.
Last time I saw him was at a gas station.
He's got some crazy fucking truck,
some weird thing.
I was like,
what is that?
I never even saw one of those things before.
I don't know what it is.
And then you got a whole bunch of what you never seen before is,
you know,
like what is that?
Oh,
that was from something new.
Uh,
some new custom made weird fucking truck.
Right.
It looks like from the future.
Does he drive it?
I'll just,
he was driving it.
Yeah.
He was a,
yeah.
Good Dude.
He never did it.
No,
I think he's doing more standup again.
I heard he's doing more standup,
but you know,
how do you,
that's a tough thing to do to probably to get that level as an international,
a list superstar,
to still have the passion to do stand up.
Right.
You got to want it.
You gotta want to do it for some strange reason.
Let the motherfuckers peers in your group.
No,
I still got it.
Motherfucker.
You know who did,
who did you ever see that thing?
It was about maybe a year or so ago.
Right when bill Cosby was in the heat of all his trouble,
where Eddie Murphy did some stand up on a day s like in front of a platform that
was for,
it was an award he got at the Kennedy Center.
It was some type of cultural show.
I can't remember exactly the name of it,
but I remember,
I think Dave was a part of that tour.
That was a big deal.
But what got me was how good he was.
Oh God damn.
He's good.
He's a comedian.
You know,
even though he's not using the stage platform,
you know,
he sits around or it's like,
oh shit.
Yeah,
that will be fun.
Of course,
you know,
I mean,
he had this whole routine about them taking bill Cosby's a doctorate degree away
from him.
He had this whole bit about it when he's doing the bill Cosby impression wise
too.
I ain't,
man,
I'm telling you,
you killed the timing was that would be so good to see him do it again.
That's what I'm thinking is,
is it was so powerful.
I was like,
God damn,
we missed out on years of this.
Yeah.
You like,
what would he talk about?
He's like probably close to being a grant.
Can you play a little bit?
I don't know.
Maybe it's only a minute long.
Just give me a little bit.
Okay.
Scan a bunch of the music.
Here it goes.
Bill has one of these.
He says
y'all make bill.
Give his back.
When he went,
you did the trophies back.
Hostos man.
Dude,
I'm telling you,
when you watch him do this,
this routine,
you go,
oh my God,
he's still got it.
It's like he motherfucking Murphy.
I nobody hasn't done any standup in forever and it was like he's been doing it
every day.
Yeah,
but you got to look at him when he came on like certain people to just naturals
bro.
But it's so sad that he hasn't been doing it,
man.
When you stop and think,
go from raw,
you know,
delirious to Ra to nothing for all these years.
And he might be if he's not enough,
but I wouldn't say nothing.
International movie star,
you know,
but not,
you mean for sure?
Nothing is terms of his do his stand up.
Gotcha.
That's all.
I mean Wayne,
he's an international movie star,
but he could have been one of the greatest of all time if he isn't already money
is already,
you have a top 10 you got to kind of put Eddie Murphy in there of course.
But he could be number one ever.
Yeah.
If he just kept doing it.
But he made us,
it would just be interesting,
but he made his mark.
Nobody was fucking doing it.
Like we got big names and stuff now,
but Eddie Murphy was just like,
everybody was talking about him like his special job for the next day.
Everybody was quoting lines from it.
I was,
I watched it with my friend Jimmy and a with a,
a bunch of his friends and we were probably like 18 or something like that.
Like maybe raw Dylan,
1718 delirious.
So Beth and I remember we were just like,
everyone was stunned.
Like we were just,
everyone was sitting back on the couch going,
Oh God,
that was incredible.
Dice clay had that energy.
Yeah.
Dice clay head.
Everyone was like,
what you said when spatials were really special,
but it wasn't very many of them.
It was a couple of them.
And then whoever that person was you would,
you knew you were going to see them on TV or somewhere for like the next two
years.
Easy Dude.
I found out about Kennison from a girl that worked the front desk at a health
club that it worked out.
I used to work at this [inaudible] going to say,
what the fuck was he doing in here?
I worked at this nautilus plus and revere was a revere.
Massachusetts is like this fitness place.
Uh,
no,
that wasn't nautilus.
Plus that was,
um,
that was a,
the fucking Goddamn Boston Athletic Club in South Boston.
That's where it was.
But anyway,
this girl worked the front desk,
she goes,
I heard,
saw this comedian last night.
He got a fucking see him,
who's the most amazing comedian?
He did this joke about gay people,
fucking dead people.
Yo Do know that bit.
Not,
don't know that,
but just sentence is 20 years old.
What's that?
That sentence?
A 20 year old,
you just said he did his bit about gay people.
Fuck a so yeah.
Motherfuck couldn't even probably try to think about saying that on stage now
Brian,
it'd be a rough rough,
but the way he said it,
the way Kinison said it,
you know,
she saw me,
I went and got it on VHS after that to watch it.
It was dealt,
but she was lying on her stomach in the parking lot to pretend to be a dead body
because what had happened was he's homosexual nature,
the Kennison bit,
he's homosexual.
Necrophilia Jakks we're paying money to have a little bit of time undisturbed,
the freshest male corpse.
So Kennison lifestyle on stage and he's going,
you imagine that undisturbed commander,
he's always lying down on stage and he's like,
wow,
I can't believe this.
I guess I'm a Guy gonna go to heaven and be with Jesus.
And uh,
wow.
It feels like so much fucking made me call.
Hi.
Be like huge fucking this.
Even after your dad never ends,
it never ends.
So I'm watching this girl who's like this volleyball player,
this big athletic girl,
and she's got her body down on the ground and she's,
she's yelling out,
oh,
don't recreate.
She's like,
live keeps fucking in the ass even after you're dead.
It never ends.
And I was laughing so hard at what she was saying.
I went out and got the VHS tape.
Did it meet your stay?
Did you,
did you,
did you like just blown away?
I was blown away.
I couldn't believe it.
He's calm energy man
is a different kind of complex.
Yeah.
It didn't like you think know he was really loud but then he was loud but he was
saying shit just like that bit.
You don't have your prayer has to be to even think of that shit.
Do you know he shared something with Roseanne Barr?
Brain injury,
really brain injury,
personality change in brain injury.
Both of how he'd get cars.
Both of them are hit by cars.
How it happened.
Both of them.
Yeah.
Same thing.
I mean don't hit your kid with a car and hope they turn out to be a committee.
Do you?
Don't think you're funny,
Eh,
with Rosanne,
she was in a mental institute for nine months,
you know,
and with Kennison they said there was an abrupt change between who he was and
who he became.
He got hit by that car and then from then on he was this wild reckless,
don't give a fuck guy and this ranting raging preacher.
But it turned out to be good for oh yeah,
the dark side.
The dark side is,
and from Roseanne.
It's good for her too.
You know?
And then you,
I be done now we haven't heard.
How's that show?
Don't her spinoff?
Is it doing good?
I don't think it's doing that good.
I think it's dropping off.
Lou Roseanne is in my opinion,
like having a person with a broken leg and expecting them to kept keep up on a
hike.
She's got,
she's got brain issues.
She's heavily medicated and you know,
Adderall and marijuana and all these different things.
There's a lot of shit that's fucking with her head,
you know?
And they,
they kind of knew that when they're making that show.
I really think they did.
I really think they knew that,
but they'll roll a dice.
Yeah.
But it's also one of those things where like there's lovable parts about that
show because of the fact that she's kind of loony,
you know?
And she's self admittedly loony and self,
admittedly dedicated Trey man,
the most interesting person is a train wreck.
It's true the most.
It was the person to watch somebody you think you could probably do better or
smarter than her does.
Also,
we'd like when successful people have a giant major flaw,
like a brain injury,
whether it makes them a ramble about shit,
you know,
I don't know.
I'll push for that,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like so like levers with no brain.
But yeah,
who comes a needle?
The needle comes out.
It's shit like inject full for Kennison.
Like Kennison was a,
he was a groundbreaking comedian.
Like when I remember seeing him,
and obviously I was only like 18 or 19 at the time,
but I remember seeing him being like,
oh,
I didn't even know that this was comedy.
I didn't know you could do that.
It was a totally different,
yeah,
he didn't give a shit.
He did a show where he would call up,
he would have a phone,
he would have asked some guy in the audience,
if your heart was ever broken by a girl,
and the guy would say,
me,
what happened?
Tell me what happened.
And he goes,
well,
she fucked my,
she left me.
He's like,
God dammit,
give this pictures.
And he would get on the stage.
Hey,
hey Marcy.
Oh yeah,
I'm here.
Your ex boyfriend Tom,
this is Sam.
Fuck.
You'd said,
yeah,
we've done a phone.
It would scream at this light.
And they had her over speakers.
She's like,
what?
What the fuck?
They be screaming fucking hard
man.
And his telephone,
it was chaos.
Oh Man.
I would love to see that man.
I saw that working.
I was working as a security guard at great center for the Performing Arts.
I got to see it while it was,
I paid for it there once I got to see him live three times.
Right.
I didn't see the special,
but I saw him perform live at the comedy store or something.
I don't know.
No.
Is it a big ass amphitheatre you imagine how it felt to see he'll work the,
or oh my God.
Fuck by.
Be Out in the hallway and shit.
Trying to peek in that row started getting tight as a motherfucker.
He was so powerful and funny looking,
you know,
like everything about him,
the baret in the fucking child molester jacket.
I don't say if it's set to standards,
but it was like everybody wanted to be too loud,
fit loud fat guy with the crazy hair.
Yeah.
There was a little bit of that after that he,
he opened up a door for something that people loved.
They loved.
There's something about him that was like,
you knew that he was like genetically fucked.
You know,
it wasn't,
it wasn't a good specimen of manhood,
but he was angry and smart and confident and fucking,
and he would talk about all that.
And you make,
you know,
the part of the fact that it was physically vulnerable was part of what,
what,
what made him funny and he would just off the chain.
Yeah.
Well,
the funny thing is about,
he had some hilarious bits about being married,
about the devil coming up too.
When you're married.
Ah,
AH,
you've been married.
Oh No,
this is even gonna be scary for you.
I go,
here's where we talked to the,
so
it would be he,
he had this shit where he's like,
he goes,
look at my face,
look at my face.
Oh,
oh.
He goes,
I've been married twice
and you can't even try.
What is Joe's while doing his voice now you can,
you can do Seinfeld and you kind of do you to be here.
Somebody do they voice even yell a little bit like,
all right,
calm down Sam.
Kinison.
Exactly.
Oh
Wow.
Yeah.
He had some,
he had some groundbreaking shit where you,
you watch it and it was all like you were on a ride,
like all the sudden there was this new thing going on.
What's this our Saturday night live?
I don't think so.
No,
It was a total shut up.
He would have.
They banned him from a lot of things.
By the time we got to a certain stage and his comedy career,
there was certain subjects and certain,
you know his bit about aids.
It was so ruthless and it was like you guys do.
Then he goes,
everybody says age shouldn't make fun.
Eight Sam,
it's communicable disease.
He'll straight people get it till he goes,
hey ma
something.
I remember hearing that going,
Whoa,
fuck you.
It's not our dance.
I'm like,
oh my God.
And uh,
there was certain bits like that where people like cut.
Yeah.
It would be like comedy police everywhere.
I mean,
so much of his bits we're punching down.
It was the argument that I got in with the guy who wrote a book on comedy and he
was telling me the comedy always has to punch up.
And I said,
no,
it doesn't.
That's crazy.
I go,
Sam Kiss and had one of the greatest bits of all time.
Two of the greatest bits of all time.
One,
there was a dude who's getting
fucked in the ass after he was dead.
Yeah.
Committee that nominated and made that one of all times,
but go ahead.
And then the other one was the bit about watching someone,
Oh,
this one burnt,
I lost the Asher and the other one was a bit about us watching a commercial to
will you please donate money to feed the starving children in Africa?
And he's saying,
which just occurred to us,
you know,
like there wouldn't be world hunger if you people
move where that photo,
he has this horrible fucking joke and there's a SARS punching down of all time.
He's making fun of starving children and it's so good.
It's just an observation.
I call it an observation and,
and he's like,
he goes,
hey,
we got deserts in America too.
We just don't live it.
I'm asshole.
He goes,
don't send them food,
sending you emails.
Send.
I'm sounding like me.
He's getting his,
he kept going to take you where the food and they,
that's all they need to do is simple.
He had a joke where he was saying,
he literally saying,
see that,
see that.
It's fucking sad.
No one's going to be a hundred years from now fucking pack your kids cash.
We didn't take you where the food is as fun.
You were crying and it was the most ruthless and wrong thing that anybody could
ever say.
You're talking about starving children and it was,
you can manage down,
you can make it all work.
We can make it all work.
He,
you can hunt you down with earthquake like effects.
Boom.
What a punch.
I probably killed it at the end with a punch.
It was unbelievably funny and it was one of the most punched down things you
could ever do.
He's making fun of starving babies.
I think it could be done.
You can make fun of anything.
It's just,
we have to know that we have to know two things.
One,
it's not really happening the way you're saying it cause you're just joking and
it's comedy.
It's a observation.
Yeah.
Somebody said Donald can a joke be too soon and I don't think it's a joke.
Could be too soon,
but it never could be too.
So for funny observation is the observation that we say we can go,
we could go to a fucking funeral being up mother phone inside laughing like
crazy.
Yeah.
And everybody would go,
going to tumble.
When will,
I'll see you in heaven when you go to heaven,
assuming that everybody's going to go to heaven,
one of the best buy is not going to go to heaven.
One of the best lines,
one of the best one liners I ever heard was from Dave Foley.
I was on news radio with Dave Foley and after Phil Hartman and gotten murdered
by his wife and then his wife committed suicide.
Yeah.
He was up for an Emmy and Hartman was,
yeah.
So we all wet,
you know,
uh,
and we all put
on suits and shit and went to the Emmy's and uh,
he did what the dude from a Frasier one and day fully turns to look at us and
goes,
what the fuck's he have to do to win?
And we're just
one of those things in the moment are murdered friend just lost at the Emmy's
and he turns to us and goes with the fuck does he have to do to win and me and
Steven Rude,
we're falling down in our chairs were like,
no,
you didn't.
That's fuck a funny.
There's no,
there's no too soon.
That's just not funny.
Y'All motherfuckers say it's too soon.
I'm like not always going to be,
it's going to be too late because the minute you're saying it's too soon,
somebody is bug jump on as shit.
Exactly.
Fucking exactly.
When you think about it,
that's what he has to go down.
I this why I have this bit about that dude who was a visiting that uncontacted
tribe and trying to convert him to Jesus and they shot him up with arrows and
say that it was an internet thing and it's a story that's on the news and I made
sure I made fun of it that day.
The moment I read it,
I started writing.
I not letting anybody out of this one.
I visited an uncontacted tribe with bibles and then you're like,
this,
I got to go set tonight.
Tonight's right now.
Right now I called up Adam,
I'll be like,
Yo,
you got to hook it up dude.
I'm filled out.
I feel that way sometimes man.
It's like,
fuck it,
I'm going for it.
Sometimes you just have to jump on something.
If it doesn't
make my stomach rumble a little bit,
a little uncomfortable,
it's,
it's like,
it's funny but it's not like,
you know,
it's not your gut funny.
I want my gut to be happy.
You don't want,
one thing that I think we should really say is,
uh,
we should really thank all the real comedy club fans that are still coming out.
And one of the things that we're not getting what guys like you and me perform
wild people when we perform in front of comedy clubs,
when I can,
a lot of pushback,
man,
we're getting a lot of good crowds,
man.
It's great crowds and they want to,
they want to hear that fucking voicemail.
And I hear that crazy shit
like with me,
it's weird because like I'll do shelves,
I'll do like an improv saying and Cleveland some shit and then I'll have a sold
out show and I'm still club.
I dabbled willow theaters unless I'm with a group of people,
whatever.
And I was like,
how many people follow me on social media?
And it's like out of a room of like 500 it'll be like four people.
And I'm like,
wow,
that's fucked up.
But the thing is the show is still sold out,
you know,
so it's not followers.
I really believe I have real fans,
you know,
like people that,
whether it's through Instagram doesn't have to be there,
but they notice dude,
they want to see them.
And also the best shit,
the crowd that comes out to see you for sure.
100% you know,
it's one thing and we can't
take anything for granted.
It's one thing to like go up like at a night at the comedy store where you know
it's gonna be a million comics,
you know,
it's going to be everybody in the stage.
You know you've got to and this another thing and you perform it,
but it's another thing knowing when the people that are there are there just to
see you,
you know when they make a weekend of it,
you know that's dope.
It is.
It's a great responsibility too,
right?
Yeah.
But you're married to it but,
but when it's,
when it's like your only option for the most part,
that's all I do now.
You know?
So it's good.
Yeah.
But it's your hair care and control your own destiny,
man.
I just think the only thing you missed since the podcast,
your podcast where you gigantic.
I think I want to do it,
John,
you have to do it.
I'm telling you.
He tells me like we'll be talking to,
he'll be like,
son,
where are you gonna do?
I said I'm doing Joe Rogan's podcast.
He was like,
yeah,
but sun when you going to do yours you need to do one like you're so good at
this.
Let's set it up.
Set it up.
Chamie too with Donnell Rawlings too soon.
Yup.
I like it.
That's it.
That's the name.
Lock it up someone by too soon.
Dot.
Don't be a dick.
Don't
get to y'all done now and I'll reimburse you on paypal cash.
Get cash out.
That's where you're going to tell people.
Yeah.
You mean uncle pay pal?
You can't say paypal is a sponsor of this podcast.
It is cash app.
It's is shit but pauses cash.
Happy for anything.
They will not pass.
You can't say paypal.
You got this cash app but I said it.
It's like saying,
oh Joe's coming over guys.
Nah,
cause he bringing this pay pal account.
Pay Pal's great for buying things online.
You don't use it.
Yeah,
but it's got the cool shit.
Cash apps.
The cool.
I'll cash app yet.
I have a cash app I think too.
I'll do that.
I want to do one.
I got to do it too soon with Darnell.
I got to do it this year.
You should get it tomorrow.
You should literally do it tomorrow,
man.
Yeah.
For Real.
You really good at it.
It'd be great.
I'm going to stay natural.
It doesn't even make sense that you're not.
I'd be honored to help.
I want to do it.
Let's do it.
I've got a podcast mother fucker.
Why not fuck with the podcast,
motherfucker.
I uh,
I try to do what Yo podcast,
you are the king of the podcast,
but I got lucky.
I got in early,
but I love podcasts and I know I would love to listen to yours.
I'm going to do it part.
It sounds like a love fest.
I'm going to do a park.
You 100% should do a podcast.
It will a hundred percent be gigantic.
I guarantee your podcast would be like number one in iTunes within another
couple of months.
100%,
a hundred percent probably the first episode because the top people want to hear
it.
And so how would I,
how do I launch it?
I'll let you back.
Um,
well I'll,
I'll tweet it for you.
You tell me when you're doing it.
I'll put it on Instagram for you.
Jamille help you find a way to set it up.
Just get you either with a microphone and a friend or you know,
another comedian or whatever.
These things are important to engage with other people or can you do it?
Bill bird does it entirely on his own.
It's amazing are you should fear does some of the best shit he ever does on his
own or he has these like long introductions.
Hill of a podcast is two hours but as introduction as an hour and it's just
already talking shit and it's some of my favorite stuff that he does delete.
It does it by himself to deleted.
And Theo Theo knows to buy himself a lot of people do them by themselves.
You know,
I need to do what I really need to do one.
Well you,
you're really funny with other people.
I mean if you could probably be just as funny by yourself,
but you're really,
you're a funny due to interact with,
you know,
like I think you and another person would be great and you know,
you could just have a friend that's also a comedian.
The two you just start,
you don't have to have guests.
You could just be talking shit about things that are going on in the news or
talking shit about life.
We're talking shit about,
you know,
any pick a subject,
you could have Q and A's from the crowd.
They could ask you questions through email and you can read out those questions.
Why not man,
I have to do one a hundred percent.
It's been calling me.
I know.
Let me help you with it.
All right.
I mean,
how would I turn that down?
You can't,
we're in,
she said,
we look like the black and white version of each other.
Thank you.
I don't know what,
I don't even know what to say about that,
but it does look like a lights light me.
That's hilarious.
I got a pest.
Fun.
I guarantee you I have way more neanderthal.
I've 50% 7% more neanderthal and the average person,
motherfucker,
that ain't,
that's not as hard as it seems,
especially if you have a rifle,
but you still got to focus.
Yeah.
For rifle you do.
But for a bow and Arrow,
that's when you really have to focus.
But it's,
um,
I just immediately here.
Um,
but it's an honest way to get meat.
You know,
I think like it's taught like you know what?
Look,
there's a honest way to earn new jokes.
This is the honest way to do standup.
Does an honest way to get meat.
I don't think everybody should do it.
You shouldn't have to,
shouldn't want to win.
A lot of people wouldn't if you told the average person,
all right,
you want chicken and just show him like six Hinz alive and it was like you went
chicken.
There you go.
That motherfucking chicken where rock before motherfucker was able to skin it
and do whatever they do to him.
But that's just how we're being raised.
It's a denial issue.
It's not a reality issue.
Cause the reality is we're still eating animals like crazy.
The denial is no one's killing them.
There's like a tiny,
tiny,
tiny got to get somebody to do your dirty work.
Exactly.
So because someone's doing your dirty work,
you don't think it's dirty,
but everybody's went,
this is how this is the shit to get vegans caught out there.
Yeah.
This conversation will turn them off into a Vegan a little bit.
There's something.
This does.
Look,
there's some,
there's a reason why so many people except veganism is because there's a lot of
really good points with a bill.
The biggest point is less animal cruelty.
You don't wanna see animal suffer.
I don't want to see animals suffer.
Yeah,
but you know what?
I don't hear you.
You are absolutely right,
but I don't hear people push that side of it as much as the,
the
dietary habits of it.
You know my side,
I hear like it's carrots in this,
but you don't hear about,
no,
it's more about the animals.
You know what it really is?
There's two things.
It's,
it really is all about the animals for a lot of them,
and they're really right that it's better than the standard American diet that
he eaten.
Vegan food and healthy vegetable food all the time.
As long as you do it correctly is way better than a standard American diet.
That's also like fish is good for you.
She says it's good for you.
Peace Salmon piece of salmon is good for you.
Wild Salmon,
that shit's really good for you.
Good for you.
It is good for you.
This idea that it's not good for you is kind of crazy,
like meat is good for you.
The real problem is sugar and bullshit.
And when you guys got that sorted out with the Vegan Diet and some people have
it sorted out with another diet,
the whole idea is to keep the poison out.
That's all it is.
They just get overzealous.
And then when people have an idea of something that they're doing that they
think everybody should do,
then they start telling everybody they should do it.
Yeah.
You don't want people to tell him.
Then I listen dude.
When I was a little kid,
it's like what the fuck?
And um,
the straws and the turtle shit straws.
A turtle.
The two.
Oh yeah,
the whole shit.
That's toxic straws.
Yeah.
It was like one motherfucker turtle and understand it reached out,
but now you can't fuck with plastic straws.
He had,
there was someone,
I retweeted their posts.
I wish I could remember who the fuck's at it,
but they were,
they were laughing about how you can't buy straws,
but at Starbucks they still have those plastic lids.
I quit.
He,
I know he,
every straws made out of paper.
You gotta ask for it.
I want us.
And then you get a paper Straw and I shake it all slop is just,
they're both understand it,
but somebody started it and motherfuckers a fucking running with,
but you know,
they can make hemp plastic that's biodegradable.
They don't have to use this same stupid plastic that's made up dude him the hips
about to change the world.
I'm about to shut up the natural cannabis I met these people told me that gave
you one of those books most likely to put,
you probably have the book,
it's got artwork.
It's really,
really dope.
The canvas people doing natural cannabis,
but it's like,
you know,
and now business people always hand on us.
Yeah,
always.
But this was like,
it was art.
It was like,
it was like just little nugs of each strand.
And then it had word from,
they had a different artist.
Tait Fletcher gave me that.
That was a big ass book he gave me at the comedy store.
I saw Tony with one and then ivy over there.
He gave me one and it's dope and shit.
But when I,
this is the first time I saw something there may be looked like,
okay,
this is the direction.
Like everybody's going to be involved with it.
So these students,
everybody,
these dudes over here brought me a war case,
that war chest
over there.
Would that championship belt on the top of it,
that war chest at the bottom,
that box.
That's all we'd man.
Jesus Christ.
I'm gonna open it up.
It's got LEDs.
You want to see what it looks like?
Fuck yeah,
I got this box.
Joe Is walking over to the box.
He might've forgotten that.
No one has a microphone.
No microphone.
That's all we'd
sorry folks.
I want to leave you hanging and ladies and gentlemen,
but
I think today's the birth of a new podcast.
Seminars about the,
someone sent me,
they already bought two soon.
Went Don L.
Dot com.
Oh,
beautiful.
So he has to start it.
They bought it,
bought it.
They're going to get it to us and we're going,
we're going to paypal them like regular white people.
I'll use the cash app.
I'll sign up tomorrow.
I'll use the codeword Rogan and I get five bucks.
That's hilarious.
Just grab shit.
Whatever you want,
man.
That's the whole deal with that box.
That's the box of doom.
Shout out to a Gino from LSP.
We'd for hooking that up.
Uh,
lots it,
if you're in the middle of nowhere or you're in one of those states,
it's still clinging to a prohibition.
You don't understand.
And uh,
I know you have it all.
We'll get you a bag if you want.
You want a bag?
This places that we'd get arrested for all this and here in California
drops.
Yeah.
The future of a California is a hundred percent legality were legal.
These other states,
their future,
they need to catch up.
They need to pass.
Some laws were living in the future.
What it we're living in the legal weed future.
Yo,
I'm telling you man,
this shit,
this shit right here.
La would make you a snob.
Yo,
La,
west coast,
any other coast from La.
When you go back people like,
oh,
I got wheat and you'll be like this what strand?
And they're like,
what the fuck you mean was tree?
I got some loud,
I got so fire,
I got some gas.
But this is dope.
But you can't underestimate weed in some places.
One Time Ari and Joey Diaz and I,
we got cocky.
We were doing a show in Philly and they gave us some weed,
but like it's Philly weed man.
That's the worst when you name it after the city is filling,
we thought it was going to be like,
like low grade weed because it's in Philadelphia.
But the guy got ahold of some oh Gee Kush strains from like 2001 and brought it
back to Philly and we were crippled.
We wish you guys had to be the type of company that you knew you would have to
find the best shit yet.
But he didn't know it was going to be that good.
Right.
Like,
if I knew it was California,
we'd I would have backed off.
Right.
It's a different thing.
Was just say Nay California.
Well,
and Denver's get that.
Yes.
I want to.
Who's going to be the next Gangsta State Oregon.
Don't get the right rain,
you know Oregon?
Nope.
It's gotta be like Philly.
Something like you can say really quick.
Yeah,
it's a,
but this,
it's hard to find bad weed today.
Weeds everywhere now.
Yeah.
You got to think about the type of friends you have that would give you pay
waves.
Yeah.
There's no need for that at this comedy club down in Tampa or something.
I was like,
you got some weed?
She was like,
yeah,
I got some weed.
I was like,
alright.
So she gave me this joint and she said,
yeah,
some shit we,
but here you go.
And I said,
what are you giving it to me for it?
She was like,
you wanted the weed.
When I was like,
why would I want some shit?
Wheat?
She got mad at me as if I was ungrateful.
I want to say,
bitch,
are you smoking?
What else to say?
I want to say it but I couldn't say,
but I'm like this,
Yo,
why would I want to smoke some weed that you just told me it was garbage just to
say thank you.
Fuck that.
You can keep that shit.
It makes sense to keep it right.
Yes.
Damn.
It just childproof I look like a crack head making some of those hard to get off
now.
I swear they're not looking at these are the best you can tell.
That's good stuff.
I know.
Potent.
I know there's different levels.
There's this three different ones.
Three different colors.
Find what you like this,
we got some batteries back there too
cause right now man,
go grab one of those.
Um,
zip up.
There's a few of them.
There's three or four of them were these joints?
Yeah.
No,
I like those little vape pens.
They're great.
And you,
you,
you could regulate it there.
Good.
Once he figured out what it is,
what are these?
Cause a charger for that.
Once you feel like what it is like you get this little battery looked like it
changed.
No,
it's just a USB.
That's a USB port.
Screws into the bottom of the base of the battery.
All right.
Don't nobody moves.
They steals.
Oh wait,
hold on.
No.
Damn.
It feels like you're in the hospital when you get home,
you're like got roll.
You got it.
You got,
Oh,
I'm about to get a shot.
Yeah,
that's a weird call.
Once you got a disposable battery.
No,
rechargeable with that little USB thing.
That thing right there.
Does it work?
What are you gonna do with that one?
Is that a five pressure check?
Sometimes you press them for notes on.
There we go.
Are,
there you go.
Powerful.
Lasp we,
Yo,
this looks so cool man.
Yeah,
it is cool.
but in La we get it delivered folks.
So you're rubbing it in man.
All these people out there,
we're not going to be showing the corner.
It'll actually change it.
All I'm saying is it's aspire,
aspire to inspire,
heat moving.
But you can in California you cannot transport.
Can you mail?
We know now that you can fly with it.
They will let you fly.
Went to [inaudible] get caught with that cause everybody,
you're the third person,
not court,
but you're the third person to say how easy it is.
Everybody's like this.
Oh yeah,
they'll let you,
I'm like,
okay.
They won't let you land though.
That's the issue.
That's what the problem was.
Somebody in Boston told me that shit.
Yeah.
If you land in Delaware,
they'll put you in a whole,
Yo,
what the fuck did this?
It's like you can't do it.
No,
it's still stupid.
And like a bunch of states.
It's only legal in what,
nine states now?
I think it's legal in nine states.
And maybe a few more magnetically.
How many all tolls or for legality?
Recreational.
I think it's still only four.
So what is that?
But it's Nevada too.
So it's Nevada,
Nevada,
California,
Oregon,
Washington and Colorado.
That's five.
Okay,
so five and Boston.
Boston has six.
Three C.
Yep.
Um,
I think I may check on that.
I think I can ask when we were there,
but they might not have their stores open yet,
sort of thing.
Oh,
hi.
Finest medical.
And it just there now medical.
See what Massachusetts has.
I want,
I'm pretty sure Massachusetts has recreational will.
Come on man.
We're grown adults.
Something else needs to go in here Joe.
It is,
it is.
Yeah.
Massachusetts is
pretty ass pouch is pretty right?
Yes.
Nice.
Yeah.
What company is that?
What does it say on that loud,
loud shout out to loud.
Loud and clear.
I love those little things cause they give you,
you know what?
That's a good dose.
Before you go onstage,
just a little,
a little quick.
Yeah.
Just a little woo.
Just a little pick me up.
Yes,
of course.
Yup.
What is your pre show ritual?
Do you have one?
No,
no.
I like to have like,
like you said,
two puffs a week.
Two puffs,
a little bit.
A little puffs.
So deep track.
No little puff.
You know Dave got me back on blunts.
Yeah.
When I first walked I was like,
Joe,
slow down man.
We get it.
You're cool mother fucker.
That's all we use it most of the time now.
When,
uh,
Charlie Murphy got me on him the first time and then,
um,
I got,
I was like,
this is an interesting experience to be high and then nicotine high at the same
time.
The two t two of them together are unique.
It's a different feeling.
And then I didn't do it again for a long time until uh,
I smoked with Dave and John Mayer namedrop assuming that were were both smoking
that it's nice guy.
Yeah,
he's a dope guy.
He's a very,
very nice guy.
Like these vapors shit like square it off,
squared out a smells.
Smells is shit.
Oh like aroma therapy.
He has been,
he does his motherfucking just,
Yo,
I'm telling you,
you got to watch out cause he'll just,
you could tell when he'd get his enrollment therapy thing in his head because
he's just doing like this.
Right.
And then he'll just come by and be like,
so how's everything right in half and did,
it's probably real though.
It's real,
but he's supposed to give me what are the motherfucking machine and my wand.
Yeah.
I'm like,
I liked it wrong.
He had like,
it was um,
like Laberdy or something.
He was like,
it was a crazy color,
crazy way.
He was like,
just Kim just doing like this
wizard.
What's that smell that you gotta be careful of?
Oh,
but truly equals hippies.
Is it a put you the oil?
It's like a type of oil that like people were wearing,
like a lot of hipsters were wearing Ryan,
isn't it?
Is it a hipster thing or a hippie?
More hippie,
Hippie,
hippie.
But what it's supposed to do,
just a sticky oil people put on it's petroleum oil.
Up here in here,
I have some lotion.
I don't have a witness like organic,
which some magical elements.
There's pretty good magical elements.
Yeah.
So what does John Mayer trying to do with this aroma therapy wand?
He's waving around everyone.
She just wants sinuses to be open,
man.
I think he cares about people breathing.
That's considerate,
you know?
But he was,
when he has,
and he's like a different person.
I mean,
it's like he like,
like it's powerful and he brings it around people that have been drinking.
So now you've got to mix the smell of fucking rum and his got damn lavender
machine and he only has one machine.
So once he gets you addicted to it,
you got to chase him.
And he's a little too handsome.
I don't even care about that part.
I just don't want him to have me chasing him for smells because the last two
times I've seen him,
I was like,
John Man,
what's up with the fucking um,
vapor thing?
He was like,
you like that,
don't you?
Like he's got like a pimp.
He wants to hold it back from you.
I'm a find out who makes it?
Let me get my home.
You should get your home.
Maybe I can get them to sponsor my new podcast.
I bet they would do it too soon too.
So I like it.
It's birth born right here.
Yup.
It's inevitable.
I like it.
It's perfect.
I get to talk every how often do what I have to do it anytime you want.
It's a thing.
Yeah.
You can take time off.
Ari Shaffir.
When he went to Asia,
he went on a walkabout for like,
what is it,
three months,
more than three months,
Archie fear vanished off the face of the earth,
disconnected from social media,
from his phone,
from his email,
everything.
Bought a burner phone and went to Asia and just traveled around for months and
months and months and months and months and he just didn't do anything.
And then he came back after three,
four months and it just pick right up where it left belong before and now he's
one a week.
Do
it,
man.
I've got to do it.
It's easy.
You could literally it from your phone.
I got to do it.
And it's like,
I think people want,
people want me to do it.
I think I want you to do it.
I'm doing it.
Let's do it.
Jamie wants you to do it,
Jamie,
is that it?
Yeah.
People want to test simple math.
So simple.
Oh,
got dance.
I make power moves.
We'll help you out.
It's super easy little bitch.
You can't fuck with me if you want it to.
Deeds,
space of dcis,
dcis,
red bottles.
Deeds is blurred.
It should say Lou itch Kate,
cause that's what I'm saying you can't for would be if you were to,
you could use that as your opening music.
Man.
I'm telling you.
That's it.
You can't fuck with me if you want it to.
Dcis,
dcis,
rare dcis gutter.
These is better.
This is Brooklyn shoes.
Say Law Bitch.
You can't fuck with God if you want it to.
These the specific dcis.
Butters.
These is Brooklyn shoes.
Please welcome too soon.
Hit the store.
Kopan both bitch.
How God choose and a quick cut of Nigga up so don't get comfortable.
Huh?
Okay.
That says no bleeps.
That's perfect.
I want to do it.
The other thing is that the,
yeah,
no bleeps ever do it all fuck ups and all.
Let it roll.
Yeah man,
I want to do it.
You should do it.
I'm going to do it 100% yeah.
Everybody was assigned my friends like everybody was like geeked out.
You're doing Joe's podcast,
you're doing Joe's podcast.
That's awesome.
Like,
I can't wait,
but my friend keeps telling me,
he says,
Donnell,
fuck that.
Do your own.
You should do your own.
He's right.
Your friend loves you.
It's quite obvious.
So making a lot of sense.
I like the fact that I know motherfuckers and get wolf's Wolf's that's a wolf
outside,
right?
In Akron.
Where off in London.
Yeah.
I don't know how to feel the feels very,
you can,
um,
you know the thing about your podcast too is,
uh,
with,
with technology today,
you could literally do all of it on a phone.
Like you don't need,
if you don't feel like,
if she feel like fucking around for a little bit and get your feet wet,
you could do everything from your phone.
You get stream from your phone,
you record from your phone,
you can do everything.
What about,
could I do,
um,
just,
uh,
just have recorded and then it may be an APP,
but if I've recorded like I'm a voice memo just wears his point just to have my
voice.
It has to be on a certain
platform.
Oh yeah.
Well,
the voice recorder,
like on a phone line on an iPhone,
the voice notes I have made,
uh,
at least a dozen podcasts could use that.
Yeah.
Just with that,
that's been a dozen podcast.
Lot of them on planes like me and Tony Hinchcliffe would be on a plane.
I just have the phone between us.
We just started talking shit and drinking cocktails.
Laugh.
The more important thing is the compensation.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
it doesn't matter.
I mean there's as long as you do your bit,
like right now we have a real professional setup.
We have a desk,
we have microphones.
Jamie's a real audio engineer.
He knows exactly what he's doing.
Everything sounds amazing,
but as long as you put the effort to give people a good solid product,
occasionally you can have one where you just talking on a phone,
they won't be upset.
It'll acts to be kind of cool.
Like people will know all these guys are on a plane.
You can hear the,
the,
the stewardess comes over with,
that's not normal.
It's not normal.
But,
but you could totally do that too.
The thing is like if you just started doing that,
people would love it and then let it to sort of figure its own,
you know as,
as it gets bigger figure it's own path,
but you don't,
you don't need a big investment to start.
You just need one of them little zoom recorders.
I got a zone.
Yep.
Perfect.
Microphone to my grandma.
Got My,
I need to just do it bro.
Just do it.
That's got to do it.
And you could,
you could do this.
The thing,
here's the thing with me,
why I was probably somewhat hesitant.
I'm like man,
everybody got a Goddamn podcast.
Yes,
but,
but the,
but if you're with the right network of people and you're with the right network
of people,
people recognize if you're,
you're in the network of people with,
we're talking about,
you did Theo show,
you do my show.
You'll do Joey Diaz is show.
Have you done Joey show yet?
I haven't done,
you'll do Joey show.
Everybody does everybody show?
Yeah.
All these guys funny people.
You do their show and then everybody knows.
Oh,
okay.
And then it's all in the same group of he and everybody gets a bump.
Everybody gets a bump.
Everyone,
if as long as everybody is succeeding and everybody's doing well and is more and
more podcasts,
and if I say,
hey,
you should see this guy's podcast,
you see
for the black people that are listening right now,
could you please take a note of what Joe just said for the last minute?
Networking,
the got a network,
all the family,
it's everything.
And more importantly,
everybody gets a bump.
Everybody gets above and pleadings eat,
including me,
everybody who's even the people that are making more money,
they make,
they're,
everything's better for everybody.
And it feels better.
It feels better when everybody's doing great,
man.
I'm telling you,
I'm with you 100% on that.
And that's like I,
which 100% on it?
It is not.
It's really simple.
Yeah,
it's really simple.
It's,
um,
it's hard when you're struggling because when you're struggling and you feel
isolated and you feel alone,
you feel like it's you versus everybody else.
But it's really not.
And one of the things about comedians is we've,
we've had this conversation many times.
We were trying to figure out what the number is.
I don't know what the number is,
but it might be less than a thousand on the whole planet,
on the whole planet earth,
a 7 billion people that might be a thousand legit Comedians,
and I'm probably being a real generous when I say that I went through 100% if I
run into a dude like you or
a,
you know,
any other real legit comedian does a,
that is a rare human being.
There's not a whole lot of us.
If we don't stick together,
who the fuck will whose farms going off?
Did you go to sleep?
The only guy wearing a dream?
Imagine if we just,
that alarm went off and I woke up to pee and I was like,
fuck,
I was dreaming.
I feel like it as the epic podcast.
Yeah,
man,
I really,
I really believe that.
I really do believe that.
I believe,
but I believe that about all that shit.
It's all,
it's good for everybody.
It's good for all of them.
As I was saying,
I was making a point that if funding but making a point and I was like black
folk that are listening right now,
listen to this strategy and listened to what he just said.
Listen to what he just said.
It's,
it has nothing to do with anything other than community.
All the other shit that's in your head in terms of competitiveness is in your
own head.
When you have that stage,
that's your stage.
You're there for 15 minutes or 20 minutes,
whatever you said is that's yours.
What everybody else does should be fuel.
It should inspire you and you should.
We should support each other because there's not so many of us telling you bro,
and that's the I'm with you 100% but that is the one of the troubling factors
and a lot of communities like to support goes away.
You,
I made motherfuckers talk,
they talk,
everybody talk,
but you know why I really believe this.
Why is it support goes away,
famine mentality,
feminine.
What do they fit it feel like there's not enough for everybody.
Everybody had this feeling for the longest time with is not enough for
everybody.
And I think that's a crazy way to think of things.
There's more than enough for everybody.
There's 300 million people.
How many fucking people do you need in your audience?
Like you said,
he should realize if you,
if you really enjoyed doing standup,
you'd want these people to become fans of stand up.
So you'd want to tell him about all these other comedians.
Tell him about Joey Diaz Talin Bout,
you know,
fill in the blank,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
whoever it is that you think is Hilaire tell them,
tell them.
There's a lot out there to see Matt.
It's a separate time.
I'm telling you,
certain communities,
they just don't want to,
they don't want to tell motherfuckers be just on this,
on himself and themselves so much.
They don't want to help.
They don't want to reach out to.
And it's like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like the conversation you're having with me right now,
it's simple for you because you know,
those are the type of friends and those type of people you deal with.
But some people,
you know what I mean?
I do know what you mean.
Other fuck that shit.
Like,
yeah,
I look at it like people I hang with Chappelle and these other guys like we are
like,
I'm went brown,
some powerful motherfuckers,
but we're friends first and foremost.
But everybody don't think like that.
Yeah,
that's a tough one.
It is a tough one,
but it's just a matter of a shift in the way you view things.
Just look at it.
Just try it.
Don't,
don't let go of your beliefs.
Just try to look at it in another way.
Try to look at it another way.
So,
and you're,
you're way better off.
If you're a team,
you're way better off of this comradery.
Like when you do a show,
so we do a show with someone who is a murderer,
a murderer,
and they go on in front of you.
You're way better off.
If you're laughing,
we,
you're go on that stage.
You're way better off if you're loose.
Like you just had a good time laugh.
But if you're tense,
like I told you I bombed.
But Jim Brewer,
I was backstage freaking out.
I was like,
God damn,
I got to file this.
How the fuck am I going to find when I was way younger but I was going to,
I was looking at eat shit.
I knew I probably wasn't and it was a problem.
It's hard to get away from whatever your first experiences is going to be.
You got to say it's probably your first experience.
It happened like that.
Like a real bombs.
I go like,
oh I could do shit about it.
Yeah.
Like I was supposed to do 45 minutes.
I got offstage at 35 but you went back in the gym.
I did.
I had to.
Yeah,
but that,
the thing is like Jim and I've always been friends and I've been friends with a
lot of people that made me eat shit going on after him.
It didn't matter that the,
the,
the thing about it is that like an,
I've,
even after all these years,
I feel genuinely,
genuinely honored to be a part of this group of people cause we do something
that is my favorite thing to watch.
That's a group of people,
but like you say,
it's like a limited circle of light as no other way to say it,
but real motherfuckers,
it's a small circle.
This some.
Okay.
By the fuck is this about plugins like you,
like they say he thinks somebody say somebody's name and you're like this,
okay,
I
heard you right.
You're like urgent,
but this is the real folks.
And like you say,
they gotta they gotta stay United.
I tell you,
a couple weeks going,
I was with David,
he said,
Morton,
he's a comedian.
It's time to grab our balls because now more than ever,
we are the only people that we've,
we have to talk about what's fucked up in the world.
Yes,
we have to.
We can't keep it tells self no,
it's not fair to nobody.
It's too confusing right now because it's too dangerous to have any
controversial ideas.
People are getting in trouble for Lou.
You don't have no balls though.
Well,
you own it.
You own it.
If you own it,
you own it.
Yeah.
You turn it,
you know,
and as they did normally I'm telling you if you have a like a good people know
your character.
If you own it,
they know what you meant to say.
They know.
They know exactly.
Come on man.
Really if you own it that someone was asking me,
why do you think Charlie,
she never got me Tude I was like what is,
what are you going to do to him?
But he hasn't already done it himself.
The guy was on here,
NBC good.
No American smoking.
You know as you know why they didn't meet nobody.
Me Too.
Cause they didn't want him to have another show.
Ah Right.
Think about it.
If he would've got me today,
he had been the headlights and he would have failed to show somewhere.
Let's talk about that collectively.
There was a period of time where Hollywood lost her fucking mind and they were
giving out these deals where if you got a certain amount of episodes,
they signed you up for a hundred episodes and that's what happened with anger
management.
Charlie Sheen show Charlie Sheen more money off
that show that he did it even off three and a half men.
But people don't know that.
People don't know that.
He knows that he's only one.
Denise.
No.
Yeah,
he's young.
Little bit.
It's a crazy story.
They used to sign shows,
TV's $200 million Charlie Sheen experiment.
They used to sign these shows and they would sign these shows in the
anticipation of the dual goal of success.
Right.
So they did that with him.
They did it with George Lopez.
He would cut money from shows.
They give you a certain percentage,
you know,
and it's like,
I don't know how it's structured,
but apparently the point is that they sign up for a giant number of shows,
not 13 not 22 they sign you up for a giant number of shows and by doing that
somehow or another,
they,
you know,
right after Charlie Sheen had his whole scandal leaving two and a half men,
he went on to have a wake,
make way more money than ever before.
That's crazy.
He's a,
he's got a crazy career man.
Legit movie star.
Gigantic TV star also talks about smoking,
smoking a lot of crack.
Right?
Was he crackers talking about her coke?
What was he saying?
Doing yeah,
doing drugs.
I don't think so either.
There's no crack advocates know people like this.
Nobody's like Yo,
last night was a little weird,
you know what I mean?
Like Yo,
I got to me,
you can't say you got to be beards to be a glass of wine.
I Ted to many crack rocks.
Come on.
Ah,
yeah.
There's a certain darkness to giving it to that glass Dick.
Once you start going down that road,
you know you've already,
you've made a choice.
You know,
there's no critical thinking involved there.
That's debauchery.
Gus To happen is you chose,
everybody chooses different happiness.
I had a friend that did a lot of crack back in New York was weird.
He would,
he would have to drink like 40 ounces of a,
of a malt liquor to try to calm down because he'd be just so jacked up from the
crack.
I had a crack f ran and I was like,
I gave so many opportunities just to be cool and he crackhead.
He gave me a crack at experience was
it was awesome.
Mcdonald's,
Bro.
We was waiting for Mcdonald's.
We gave him the money.
They was like,
what happened?
I was like,
oh man.
We were like,
we know you a crack head,
but don't crack hit us.
You know what I'm saying?
Go outside of our community,
but like here,
don't do that,
bro.
Yeah.
My friend was brilliant too.
Brilliant,
brilliant guy,
but he had just like mental problems and he just needed to get high all the
time.
He had it.
Never wanted to be escape.
Yeah.
He never wanted to be alone with his thoughts.
That's a tough one for a lot of people.
It was a real one for him because he was brilliant.
He's a brilliant guy,
but he was also homeless half the time.
I knew him,
you know,
it was a lot going on,
man,
within lot going on,
but he was,
he could help him.
No,
he was too stubborn.
He wouldn't listen.
He,
he would just vanished and disappear in two drugs for a few days and then come
back and he could do math in his head.
Like you could say to him,
99 times 54 times six minus five divided by three and even when he was sold,
yeah,
and he would just bang it out.
We just tell you what it is.
Quick.
A $2,000,
can we tell you?
And you're like,
you'd be there with a calculator.
You're like,
you mother fucker.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
But he couldn't,
he couldn't manage his own brain to the point where we could stay away from hard
drugs and eventually died of an overdose.
That's usually,
yeah.
That's how it goes.
That's usually how that goes,
bro.
Yeah.
Like that to me.
Motherfuckers come back from that.
They don't come back from the needle.
Nope.
It'll come back from that.
It's hard.
I mean it is possible,
but you need some help.
That's one of the reasons why that 12th step shit works.
We really given a god or the higher power.
It's like you,
you,
you're going to have to somehow or another thing to something more important
than what you're doing.
Otherwise you're never going to stop this shit.
Yeah,
but those people become like big sex addicts and shit.
Coffee,
would they want to fuck everything?
Coffee Sign,
right?
They was cool.
Me Is some ass.
They don't give a fuck.
Give me the ass for us coffee.
Whatever it is.
You do know.
Jug.
That's so fucking funny.
It's so true.
Everybody did.
I know that had a situation,
a muffle cause I'll cough shit.
They don't ever get rid of those tendencies.
They just try to figure out a way to put it somewhere else in a positive way.
Socially acceptable or marathon running Isam.
Shit,
there's a lot of the LIGO heart,
those duly jump.
Motherfuckers
don out.
I think we birth,
we birthed a new podcast today.
Yo.
You know what I just did and I know there's a reason why.
Here's the reason why I bumped it to you in the show and we see each other in
passing.
We've been talking about doing this for a long time,
you know what I mean?
But I don't like when I see the comedy club,
I'm like,
this is the old Emma fucking working.
I'm working.
What's up?
I know you Joe Rogan,
Yada Yada.
But I was like,
you know,
you do your shit.
I was like,
but when I see,
I'd be like,
did it work?
I'm glad we had this conversation.
I just did Burt's cooking show and I took that shit oversight.
They was like,
Yo,
this might be my week of getting shows that he was like,
you should do a cooking show.
Right.
I would to birch shit.
Burton was like this.
I think I just gave my show to Darnell.
Right?
Come here.
They,
Joe Rogan's like,
Yo Donielle let's do a show.
We can do it right here.
You have to do a show.
Fuck it.
Let's do it.
You have to do a show.
Yeah.
And like I said,
you just start off easy.
Just put a microphone on your iPhone.
It's nothing.
It's easy to do.
I've got all that.
I'm going to do it.
Beautiful.
Yes.
Hey,
there's a lot of fun.
Thank time.
Always good to see you,
man.
Congratulations.
Congratulations on all your success in however many years you've been doing it.
Cause when I was first introduced,
I knew like fear factor,
you know,
I didn't even know that you did stand up until I came out here.
Wow.
I didn't know that.
I,
you know what I thought I was like,
oh,
that's the TV Nigga.
Right?
I don't believe
his sad.
I was like Delta TV bigger right here.
Right.
Then they could do podcasts too.
And then I was like that they could do stand up too.
And I was a high,
but your pocket has begun.
Right.
And then when I saw you do your show,
I was like,
he'll go hard.
Bubba fucking sir,
I appreciate your,
your,
your work ethics and everything you do.
Thank you brother.
I appreciate you too,
man.
I appreciate your,
your,
your perspective on comedy,
your approach,
your ethics,
the whole deal.
Man.
I appreciate you.
I appreciate you being around the comedy store too.
Awesome.
All right,
Donna,
ladies and gentlemen.